ok bienvenus bienvenue à tout le monde
c'est beau bienvenue à tout le monde je
suis très content de vous inviter à
cette conférence une des premières
conférences grâce à jean marc jancovici
je pense qu'il ya tellement de monde qui
veut l'écouter sur le thème de ce
week-end au mixeur une guidance qui
devient très important et surtout très
important ce moment surtout au niveau
dans le domaine où nous nous sommes
spécialisés dans les financiers la bbva
la banque espagnole vient d'émettre une
obligation
hirsch dit cette semaine et puis il y
aura beaucoup plus qui va aller lui jean
marc jancovici va vous expliquer le
derrière de ça il m'a dit déjà ça va
nous coûter à tous beaucoup plus cher
pour ne pense mais je je je suis très
heureux de vous accueillir ici et on
attend avec impatience de ce que vous ne
vous allez nous dire merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que ça fonctionne meirieu
bonsoir je vais répondre du tac au tac à
cette introduction j'ai publié il ya
trois jours je crois dans un quotidien
économique français qui s'appelle les
échos 1 une petite tribune dans lequel
ge explique l'un des signes que l'on
traitera correctement le problème dont
je vais vous parler c'est qu'il sortira
de le sg tant qu'ils restent dans le sg
on est sûr qu on traitera par dessus la
jambe comme un truc totalement
anecdotique et pas du tout à la hauteur
de l'enjeu
voilà donc ça sera un des marqueurs du
fait que le problème est pris
sérieusement
la deuxième chose c'est que je vais
faire une déclaration d'intérêts
avant cette intervention comme vous
pouvez le voir il ya deux logos sur
cette phase iii même en hausse alors que
ce que je fais dans la vie quand je ne
fais pas des interventions je suis
associé d'une entreprise s'appelle
carbone 4 qui est née il ya 13 ans en
france et qui tente d'amener le milieu
économique à être un peu plus sérieux
sur la question climatique
ce sont des heures et des malheurs voilà
c'est particulièrement dur et que le
monde financier et mernier bras au
moment des questions
la deuxième on fait à la fois du conseil
de la data donc on connaît bien votre
univers quand on essaye de vous
convaincre de nous donner un tout petit
peu d'argent pour travailler la deuxième
chose que j'ai faite c'est que il ya dix
ans j'ai créé une association
d'entreprises s'appelle dechy project
qui est donc un lobby ngo et qui a
vocation à rassembler des acteurs
économiques qui considère que c'est leur
intérêt égoïste que l'on soit plus
sérieux sur la question climatique
c'est ça l'idée donc j'essaye de faire
une collection d'intérêts égoïstes qui
se disent non moi j'ai envie
dans les deux autres casquettes que j'ai
je suis professeur à mines paristech qui
est un établissement d'enseignement dont
j'ai envie de dire quelque chose de pas
très très éloignées pour être le pfl où
j'étais ce matin
sauf que c'est plus petit des promotions
120 élèves et enfin la dernière
casquette un peu significatif que j'ai
c'est que je suis membre d'une entité
administrative qui a été créée par
macron il ya un an et demi vous savez
ils créent tous les six mois un truc
nouveau
et alors moi j'étais dans le truc qu'il
a créé il ya un an et demi sa peine le
haut conseil pour le climat ou naissance
est l'intérêt de cette instance très
égoïstement c'est que on a accès et on a
une réflexion collective sur ce qui est
en train de faire la france en matière
d'engagement sur ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre je pense que ce qu'on
racontait de nul effet sur la politique
qui est suivi à court terme
c'est un petit effet médiatique ça
permet surtout de prendre un tout petit
peu de temps pour se poser et regarder
ce qui se passe
donc je vais vous parler de climat et
d'énergie est en fait ce que je vais
vous dire ce soir si j'ai pas trop mal
réussi mon coup devrait vous faire un
peu mal à la tête pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que ces techniques et
compliqué donc il ya plein de trucs sur
lesquels je vais être obligée d'aller un
peu vite mais je le redis c'est
technique est compliqué c'est bourré de
maths de physique de biologie etc
enfin tout un tas de trucs qui vous font
mal à la tête et la deuxième
et la deuxième chose c'est que si j'ai
pas trop mal réussi mon coup aussi vous
allez vous rendre compte qu aujourd'hui
il ya un écart absolument monstrueux
entre la réalité du problème et la
réalité des moyens c'est à dire qu'en ce
moment on est en train d'aller droit
dans le mur en klaxonnant gaiement si
normalement vous devriez avoir ces deux
conclusions en fait ce que je vais vous
dire ce soir est un résumé du courroux
du cours que je fais à mes élèves des
mines et qui s est le dernier logo vous
avez au milieu disponibles totalement en
ligne sur mon site personnel vous avez
une page sur mon site personnel ou vous
avez la totalité du cours que je fais
aux mines en ligne sous trois formes à
la fois des enregistrements vidéos des
enregistrements des planches avec le son
et des transcriptions écrite donc il ya
tout ce qu'il faut voilà et maintenant
nous allons commencer à rentrer
directement dans le vif du sujet et le
vif du sujet va commencer par ça alors
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
donne depuis un siècle et demi les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'humanité alors quand je dis gaz à
effet de serre peut-être que certains
d'entre vous n'ont pas en tête la
définition précise de ce que c'est qu'un
gaz à effet de serre un gaz à effet de
serre est un gaz jeudi la définition
physique ensuite ensuite le traduire en
avec les mains j'ai envie de dire c'est
un gaz qui a la capacité qui possèdent
des raies d'absorption dans les
infrarouges de grandes longueurs d'onde
émis par la surface planétaire voilà
c'est ça un gaz à effet de serre c'est à
dire que c'est un gaz qui a la
possibilité d'avoir des transitions
électronique
dabo les cultes du gaz à la possibilité
d'avoir des transitions électronique
exactement dans les gammes d'énergie des
photons qui sont envoyées par la surface
planétaire grâce à sa définition qui est
mal à la tête
la définition qui fait un peu moins mal
à la tête c'est qu'on va dire cd
opacifiant à l'évacuation de l'énergie
de la surface planétaire sous forme de
rayonnement infrarouge encore cédé
opacifiant à cette évacuation
le premier gaz à effet de serre présents
dans l'atmosphère c'est la vapeur d'eau
mais les hommes n'ont pas d'influencé
sur la teneur atmosphérique en vapeur
d'eau pas d'influencé directe parce que
la teneur atmosphérique en vapeur d'eau
dépend essentiellement de la température
de l'air sur une planète couverte aux
deux tiers dos a suffi à conditionner la
quantité de vapeur d'eau qui a dans
l'atmosphère parce que la terre est une
grosse machine à évaporer alors on
oublie parfois parce que nous habitons
assez peu sur l'océan
mais l'essentiel de la surface
planétaire est couverte d'océans et donc
c'est une grosse machine à évaporer le
deuxième gaz par ordre d'importance et
le co2 alors là nous contribue aux
émissions on le voit sur ce graphique
puis après il ya d'autres gaz le méthane
protoxyde d'azoté et c'est la première
dès le premier des commentaires que je
vais faire sur cette courbe c'est que si
j'avais enlevé ici les dates et que je
vous avais demandé de me mettre
n'importe quel camp dire processus qui
est parfois avancé comme permettant
d'être plus efficaces en matière
d'émissions vous auriez été incapable de
le mettre d'accord
si je vous demande de me mettre sur
cette courbe le début des nerfs qui
soi-disant permettre d'émettre moins
vous êtes incapable de me les mettre
quelque part en disant ah bah ça date
dollars
c'est évident parce qu'à ce moment là
les émissions baisse et si je vous mets
le début des négociations climat c'est
pareil à quel moment est ce qu on a
commencé à avoir des négociations climat
et ça fait baisser les émissions tout le
respect que j'ai pour les nations unies
qui ont un tout petit bâtiment à genève
vous auriez été incapable de bleu m etc
et si je vous demande de me mettre
voilà si vous aussi vous dis par exemple
le digital la numérisation la
dématérialisation l'envolée des services
dans l'économie etc tous ces trucs qui
sont censés faire en sorte que notre
économie soit moins prédatrice de
l'environnement vous n'envoyez
absolument pas la traduction sur cette
courbe c'est donc que toutes ces
affirmations sont fausses
le digital n'a aucun effet de modération
des émissions aucun la tertiarisation de
l'économie n'a aucun effet sur la
modération des émissions aucun etc etc
et les quelques les quelques milliards
qu'on m'aide aussi à 22 milliards qu'on
met dans les éoliennes en ce moment
n'ont aucun effet sur la modération des
évictions aucun corps et les greens
bombe de bbva non plus n'ont pas d'effet
mais on y reviendra à la fin c'est donc
là vous avez les émissions de encore une
fois de gaz à effet de serre dont les
hommes sont à l'origine ils se trouvent
autre autre rappel de physique de chimie
plus activement essentiel tôt que de ce
premier des gaz à effet de serre le co2
ici est un oxyde co2 c'est dioxyde de
carbone donc c'est un oxyde il se trouve
que la chimie nous dit que les oxydes
sont des formes moléculaire extrêmement
stable sur terre c'est à dire qu'une
fois qu'un élément est sous forme
d'occident il faut se lever de bonne
heure pour qu'il en soit autrement
et en fait se lever de bonne heure ça
veut dire il faut mettre de l'énergie
dans le système faut apporter de
l'énergie au système pour que l'oxygène
veuille bien s'en aller d'accord une
fois qu'un événement un élément est
souvent des oxydes si vous ne touchez
plus à rien il reste sous forme d'oxydé
éternellement
c'est par exemple le cas du fer sur
certains d'entre vous ont des actions ou
des obligations dans des mines de fer et
bien le faire se trouve souffle sur
terre sous forme d'oxydé et ça fait des
centaines de millions d'années c'est à
dire depuis que l'oxygène libre dans
l'atmosphère qu'il est sous forme
d'occident qui s'est collé sous forme
d'oxydé bien il se vante d oxyde depuis
des centaines de millions d'années ça
bouge pas c'est exactement pareil pour
le co2 qu'on rajoute dans l'atmosphère
tant que le co2 est dans l'air sans
contact avec le sol
il est éternel il est éternel
parce que il n'ya aucun processus
spontanée d'épuration du co2 de
l'atmosphère le co2 totalement inerte
tant qu'il est dans l'atmosphère
les deux processus d'épuration du co2
que nous avons sur terre sont deux
processus afin dans l'atmosphère sont
deux processus de contact avec la
surface c'est quand l'atmosphère est en
contact avec l'océan vous avez d
équilibrage de concentration respectives
on appelle ça des pressions partielle de
co2 entre l'air et l'eau est à ce moment
le co2 est capable de passer de l'air
dans l'eau si la pression partielle est
supérieur dans l'air mais c'est un
processus irréversible si un jour on
retire le co2 de l'atmosphère à ce
moment une partie du co2 qui est dans
l'océan ressortira pour aller se
recoller dans l'atmosphère et vous avez
un deuxième processus qui la
photosynthèse
il faut un photon faut de l'énergie du
soleil si vos ados essaye de faire
pousser des plantes que je ne nommerai
pas dans un placard sans lumière ça
marche pas donc il faut un apport
d'énergie pour que ce processus prenne
place et à ce moment-là plantes se
charge de récupérer le co2 de casser le
truc en deux gardes le carbone pour
faire du glucose et nous libère
gentiment l'oxygène pour qu'on puisse
respirer à cause de ce que je viens de
dire
une fois qu'on crée un surplus de co2
dans l'atmosphère
ce que nous sommes en train de faire le
temps qu'il faut attendre après arrêt
des émissions pour que ce surplus
s'évacue c'est plus que les temps
historiques
vous avez ici un graphique publié il ya
des années un qui est connu dans le
monde scientifique qui vous donne ce
qu'il reste d'un surplus de co2 après
arrêt des émissions donc on a créé un
surplus de co2 aujourd'hui il ya plus de
co2 dans l'atmosphère qu'avant que l'on
commence à faire joujou avec le charbon
aux puits de pétrole et de gaz
et bien si demain matin l'humanité
arrête ses émissions au bout d'un siècle
une petite moitié en fait une moitié
retenez sa du surplus de co2 qu'on a
créé sera toujours au dessus de nos
têtes alors pas au dessus de vos os ni
des miennes au dessus de nos
petits-enfants pour ce qu'il en restera
au bout d'un millier d'années entre 20
et 30% de ce surplus de co2 sera
toujours au dessus de nos têtes et au
bout de dix mille ans 10% au moins de
surplus de co2 sera toujours au dessus
de nos têtes ce que je suis en train de
vous dire c'est deux conclusions qu'il
faut garder en présent à l'esprit la
première c'est que plus jamais dans
l'histoire des hommes
on ne reverra le climat de 1700 plus
jamais
et par ailleurs comme temps qu'il ya
plus de co2 dans l'atmosphère
il ya une opacification de l'atmosphère
qui augmente la quantité d'énergie
contenue dans le système plus jamais
dans l'histoire historique des fois dans
l'histoire des hommes
il n'y aura un climat stable y'a qu'à
partir de maintenant la dérive
climatique est une donnée structurelle
dans le monde dans lequel on vit
le climat sera différent dans 20 ans de
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui différent dans
42 ce qu'il est dans 20 ans etc
je vous rappelle que nos sociétés se
sont sédentarisés parce que pendant dix
mille ans depuis la fin de la dernière
glaciation le climat planétaire a été
remarquablement stable et donc on a plus
adaptées au climat local
les habitations l'agriculture etc
manifestement l'agriculture suisse n'est
pas l'agriculture marocaine est
manifestement les habitations suisses ne
sont pas les habitations marocaine et ça
on le doit au fait que nos générations
les gens qui nous ont précédés ont pu
génération après génération
perfectionner les conditions dans
lesquelles ils s'adapter à un
environnement extérieur qui lui ne
variait pas maintenant c'est fini c'est
à dire que l'environnement extérieur va
varier en permanence en permanence ce
que nous sommes en train de voir en ce
moment comme incendie dans le monde sait
que le début des conséquences qui vont
venir avec le changement climatique
c'est juste le début c'est juste le
début alors bien évidemment je vais vous
parler un peu des conséquences bien
évidemment un des problèmes que nous
avons avec ça et vous le connaissez très
bien dans le monde dans lequel vous
vivez
c'est que les pas de temps du problème
que nous avons à traiter non seulement
des passes une ou plusieurs vies
humaines mais dépasse de très loin les
horizons qui sont les vôtres et qui sont
les miens dans la gestion de fonds va
dire de la société de l'économie dans le
monde politique
un horizon de long terme ces trois ans
c'est à dire le temps vous commenciez à
penser à la prochaine élection à deux
ans de la fin de votre mandat et dans le
monde qui est le vôtre le long terme se
balade entre quelques nano secondes et
un an quand on a de la chance on est
juste totalement à l'ouest sur les
horizons de temps qu'on est en train de
prendre en considération pour gérer ce
problème
donc la seule conclusion absolument
certaine c'est que tant qu'on reste avec
des horizons de temps de cet ordre de
cette nature on est absolument sûr qu'on
fera rien de sérieux
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle dans
le monde financier les premiers à s'être
intéressé à la question ont été les
fonds de pension parce que c'est les
sols qui ont un horizon de temps un peu
long
d'accord give me my money back dans 20
ou 30 ans bon du coup il faut quand même
qu'ils y réfléchissent un peu après dès
qu'ils donnent un mandarin asset manager
lui il réfléchit à la déco parce que
c'est combien tu va ramener de pognon
dans l'année puis si c'est pas assez je
te change donc le on a vraiment un
problème et dans les sociétés avec
lesquelles je travaille je le dis
publiquement je peux vous le dire ça
m'empêche pas d'avoir quelques clients
les dans toute société cotée
là c'est la stratégie long terme ces
trois ans les bonnes années six mois les
mauvaises quoi donc c'est évident qu'on
est encore une fois en décalage complet
avec le problème que nous avons à
traiter
alors cette accumulation enfin les
émissions conduisent à une accumulation
de co2 dans l'air à cause de ses très
longues durées de vie là vous voyez la
quantité de co2 dans l'air mesuré en
millilitres par mètre cube
on appelle ça des parties par million et
vous voyez par exemple une expérience
qu'on fait qui consiste à avoir des
réunions internationales alors vous
voyez l'effet que ça a sur la variation
de la concentration ça ne sert à rien ou
plus exactement ça ne sert à rien de
descriptif ce qui se passera dans les
enceintes internationales
c'est juste d'entériner ce que les pays
sont déjà prêts à faire jamais ces
enceintes là ne feront naître quelque
chose de nouveau
entérinons ce qui ce qui a déjà été
décidé ailleurs alors cet officier cette
pacification de l'atmosphère au
rayonnement émis par la terre 1 a
notamment pour effet que la température
d'équilibré au sol augmente
en gros on reçoit sur terre de l'énergie
du soleil cette énergie passe pour
l'essentiel à travers l'atmosphère
puisque l'air et transparent à la
lumière c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'arrive à vous voir sinon s'il y avait
un mur opaque à la lumière je verrai pas
bien et une fois que cette énergie
solaire est parvenu au sol elles
chauffent le sol et le sol entre autres
choses va émettre de l'infrarouge parce
que c'est comme ça qu'un corps à la
température du sol se débarrasse de son
énergie un rayonne de l'infrarouge et à
ce moment c'est infrarouge lui a envie
de repartir vers l'espace sauf que dans
l'atmosphère il ya des gaz qu'ils
interceptent qui absorbent ces
infrarouge et plus c'est celle ci ça les
gaz à effet de serre et plus vous
rajoutez de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère est plus l'absorption des
infrarouges près de la surface
planétaire et efficace
et donc plus ça confine l'énergie près
du sol donc augmenter les gaz à effet de
serre augmentent la température d'
équilibre au sol ici vous avez une
courbe qui vous donne par rapport à il
ya un siècle la façon dont la
température est en train d'augmenter
enfin même plus d'un siècle la façon
dont la température est en train de se
comporter alors vous voyez que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui elle a déjà augmenté alors
on a pris 1 degré à un degré on a déjà
20 millions d'hectares qui crament en
australie + 20 millions d'hectares qui
crament en sibérie plus 5 millions
d'hectares qui crament en californe
maintenant pour moi ils sont qu'à 3 qui
crament en californie plus et c'est
justin est ce que vous voyez sur ce
graphique c'est qu'en fonction des
émissions que nous aurons plus tard que
je vous détaille pas parce que c'est pas
le sujet ce que vous voyez surtout c'est
que les 20 prochaines années sont
indifférenciés quel que soit le scénario
que nous suivons en termes d'émissions
la trajectoire de température est
exactement la même
ça c'est la conséquence de la durée de
vie du co2 dans l'atmosphère
les 20 prochaines années sont déjà
écrites du point de vue du climat
quoique nous fassions sur les émissions
quoi que nous fassions donc à partir du
moment où on commence à s'agiter sur la
baisse des émissions
on travaille pour dans 20 ans on est
obligé de s'y coller à un moment ou un
autre mais il ya vingt ans de décalage
entre le moment où on commence à prendre
le médicament est le moment où ça
commence à avoir un effet sur la maladie
c'est ça qu'il faut dire et dans les 20
ans qui nous séparent du moment où ça
commence à avoir un effet de toute façon
les conséquences en pire de toute façon
ce décalage temporel il est évidemment
extrêmement cruelle et désagréable mais
c'est un fait il faut il faut la vente
maintenant je vais vous parler un peu
des conséquences du changement
climatique et je vais commencer par une
comparaison que j'aime beaucoup qui est
que je vous montre maintenant qui va
vous donner j'espère un début de
visualisation de
avec quoi nous sommes en train de jouer
j'aime beaucoup cet exemple parce que
quand on parle à nos sens
une variation de température de quelques
degrés est un non-sujet absolue la
température extérieure à genève
aujourd'hui a probablement varier de
plus de 10 degrés alors il sauf qu'on
est dans une saison où ça varie beaucoup
mais à problèmes en varier de plus de 10
degrés entre ce matin et cet après midi
on doit pas être moins de 15
ça vous a fait rapport donnez moi
l'expression ni chaud ni froid au sens 2
est évident ce matin les étudiants cet
après midi la température en scène
extérieure a changé de 15 degrés donc
changer la température planétaire de 3
degrés soit quand même juste pas un
sujet alors en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre et c'est ça je vais essayer
de vous expliquer maintenant c'est que
une moyenne et une valeur individuelle
c'est pas du tout pareil parce que
pendant que ici c'est le jour et que la
température se réchauffe en australie c
la nuit et la température sa baisse
pendant que ici c'est l'automne et la
température descend en australie c'est
l'arrivée du printemps puis de l'été et
la température monte alors en australie
et surtout l'océan austral est en fait
la moyenne planétaire elle elle varie
pas du tout de 10 de 15 ou de vous allez
voir 4° tous les quatre matins c'est pas
du tout ça donc en fait il faut bien
raisonné quand on comprend quand on
parle de la variation de la moyenne il
faut bien comprendre que ça ne désigne
pas du tout la même chose qu'une
variation local est instantané même si
on parle de température dans les deux
cas de figure
alors le voilà donc voilà à quoi
ressemble l'europe alors quand je dis
actuelle c'est déjà plus actuelle c'est
l'europe et je vois chaque fois qu'il
faut que je pense à changer cette
légende l'europe de la fin du xxème
siècle ressembler à ça c'est à dire que
dans l'europe de la fin du xxème siècle
vous avez des conditions climatiques qui
font que si on ne coupe pas les arbres
pour y mettre autre chose à la place des
chants des routes des écoles ou des
banques
eh bien nous avons en europe des grosses
espèces végétales qui sont capables de
pousser c'est à dire des arbres donc ça
veut dire qu'il fait suffisamment humide
et suffisamment doux ni trop froid ni
trop chaud pour que prospère des grosses
espèces végétales
quand nous sommes au nord ici il fait
trop froid et trop sec pour que vous
ayez ça et quand on étale est ici fait
trop sec pour
voyez des arbres mais sinon partout
ailleurs vous avez déjà voilà l'europe
ya vingt mille ans alors l'europe ya
vingt mille ans est très différente de
l'europe d'aujourd'hui et on se situe
dans un contexte où en fait elle est
beaucoup plus froides parce que à cause
du mariage à 10 tumultueux que nous
avons dans ce système solaire donc c'est
avec le système solaire est un mariage à
10 c'est à dire le soleil +9 planète
et bien en fait l'orbité de la terre
n'est pas constante au cours du temps
parce que nous subissons la traction de
jupiter et de saturne est l'attraction
de jupiter et de saturne conduit
l'orbité terrestre à ne pas être
constante au cours du temps elle était
formée au cours du temps et cette
déformation de l'orbité terrestre a
notamment causé les grands cycles
glaciaires et interglaciaires à
l'échelle de la centaine de milliers
d'années sur les 3 derniers millions
d'années
donc ça il fait chaud il fait froid il
fait chaud il fait froid mais ces cent
mille ans dans un sens ni dans l'autre
donc il ya vingt mille ans nous sommes
au coeur de la dernière ère glaciaire il
n'y a pas de financiers suisses parce
que vous voyez que les suisses sont sous
la glace pour l'âme est réglée de ce
côté là il n'y a pas non plus le fonds
souverain norvégien puisque les
norvégiens sont sous la glace comme vous
pouvez le constater la en fait la
scandinavie et sous trois kilomètres de
glace 1 les glaciers des alpes ont
considérablement ont pris une importance
considérable nous laissant au moment où
ils ont disparu la haute vallée du rhône
et vous voyez également que pour les
français la très bonne nouvelle c'est
que les irlandais et les écossais ont
disparu du tournoi des six nations
c'est également un avantage considérable
dong wei que le paysage est très
différente pour faire ce gros glaçon qui
est là et ce gros glaçon qui est la plus
le gros glaçon qui est la plus le groupe
nation qui est posée sur le canada qui
est totalement glacée trois kilomètres
de glace aussi plus le groenland etc il
faut de l'eau comme dans votre frigo
n'avait pas bu la son sens où l'eau est
venue en totalité de l'océan et parce
que donc il ya eu un transfert d'eau et
comme l'océan est une grande baignoire
dont le fond est toujours au même
endroit le niveau de l'océan a baissé de
120 m donc vous n'avez pas monsieur
bourgnon n'importe lequel des deux qui
gagne une régate transmanche qui sait
plus de manches
le climat est beaucoup plus froid et
beaucoup plus sec est en fait il est
beaucoup plus sec parce que beaucoup
plus froid vous le savez aussi vous
n'habitez pas très loin des montagnes
quand le climat est beaucoup plus froid
en général il est sec
parce que dans un climat froid vous avez
moins d'évaporation et par ailleurs la
quantité de vapeur d'eau que vous pouvez
mettre dans un air très froid est
beaucoup plus faible que la quantité de
vapeur d'eau que vous pouvez mettre dans
un air très chaud donc un climat
beaucoup plus froid est un climat
beaucoup plus sec du reste l'antarctique
est un des endroits les plus sec au
monde et dans cet écosystème beaucoup
plus hostile où l'essentiel de la
végétation européenne ressemble à ce que
vous avez au nord de la sibérie actuelle
est bien la population française est
inférieure à la population genevoise
beaucoup c'est à dire que tout ce que
l'écosystème france est capable de
fournir à des animaux en bout de chaîne
alimentaire que sont les hommes c'est la
capacité à nourrir cent mille personnes
donc vous voyez que les deux paysages
sont raisonnablement différents et à
l'évidence quand l'europe est passée de
l'état de gauche à l'état de droite
c'est que la planète s'est réchauffé je
connais peu de gens qui arrivent à faire
fondre un glaçon en le refroidissant
donc peut-être s'y réchauffer de combien
et bien cette transformation est due à
un réchauffement planétaire qui est de
l'ordre de 4 à 5 degrés en dix mille ans
donc là vous avez le résultat d'une
expérience grandeur nature que le passé
nous offre qui est de réchauffer le
climat de quelques degrés en cinq à dix
mille ans et vous voyez le résultat
alors avant de rentrer dans les détails
maintenant je vais vous la faire courte
est bonne un réchauffement climatique de
4 degrés en un siècle fait que la valeur
des actifs que vous gérez sera le cadet
de vos soucis
d'abord il y aura plus d'actifs à gérer
parce que une bonne partie des pays
mondiaux sont en guerre
les autres sont en dictature enfin voila
c'est évident que c'est
le chaos partout parce que ce sera un
tel déplacement des conditions
existantes à une vitesse telle avec des
telles carences sur les besoins
essentiels et notamment l'alimentation
je vais vous en parle et que évidemment
ça va être le bazar partout
donc on ne restera pas du tout dans un
monde stable et les nations unies
pourront bien appeler à la paix ça
servira à rien donc c'est un monde
monstrueusement chaotique qui nous
attend et surtout les gens qui vont nous
suivre
parce que à la limite il ya beaucoup de
gens dans cette salle qui ont comme moi
quelques cheveux blancs bon signe meurs
demain matin ils en ont bien profité à
la limite 1 ils sont au delà de
l'espérance de vie de l'humanité qui
était la sienne en 1909 serait-ce qu'en
1900 je rappelle que l'espérance de vie
à la naissance en 1900 en france et est
inférieur à 50 ans donc tous les gens
qui ont plus de 50 ans dans la salle ils
ont déjà beaucoup plus profiter de la
vie que l'essentiel de l'humanité qui
nous a précédés donc mais là on est en
train de parler de nos gosses et nos
petits-enfants
ces deux qu'on aime demande est en train
de parler et eux n'ont pas tous 50 ans
donc voilà un de quoi il est question
alors maintenant un peu quelques détails
tout ce que je vous raconte maintenant
est sorti de la littérature scientifique
vous avez des sources ici vous avez
d'abord un graphique qui vous montre le
nombre de jours où les conditions
extérieures seront létale
c'est à dire qu'on sort dehors rumeurs
sur une planète qui s'est réchauffée de
4° corps par rapport à aujourd'hui
le pourquoi est-ce que c'est concentré
sur la bande équatoriale
parce que c'est une zone dans laquelle
l'air est saturé d'humidité
vous savez que la température de votre
corps est de 37 degrés en fait la
température de votre peau est de 35 de
votre front un peu plus puisque on vous
a tous pris la température pour vous
laisser rentrer ici et vous avez vu si
vous avez regardé la température qui
s'affichait vous avez vu que c'était 35
pas grand chose
la température extérieure 35 et 36 si
l'air ambiant monte à plus de 35 ou 36
degrés en étant saturé à 100 %
d'humidité
à ce moment vous vous rentrez enfin vous
êtes dans un environnement dans lequel
votre corps ne peut plus se refroidir
par déperditions thermiques et il ne
peut plus refroidir par évaporation
c'est à dire la transpiration donc vous
mourrez d'hyperthermie donc pour y
mourir vous pouvez mourir d'hypothermie
si vous êtes pris sous une avalanche et
convient pas vous chercher enfin déjà d'
asphyxie mais tombé dans une crevasse
power d'hypothermie c'est possible eh
bien là c'est les endroits où on m'aura
d'hyperthermie d'accord parce qu'on peut
pas juste
on peut juste pas se tenir dans des
conditions extérieures et vous avez le
nombre de jours par an que ça concernera
donc il ya des endroits par exemple ici
un tout petit peu peuplée par exemple
ici un tout petit peu peuplée par
exemple au nigeria un tout petit peuple
et c'est bien évidemment au fur et à
mesure que nous irons vers des
conditions de cette nature si nous y
allons les gens qui habitent là ils vont
pas rester là ils vont aller voir
ailleurs le temps qui fait alors ils
monteront pas tous dans un avion parce
que là ce moment-là y aura plus d'avions
mais enfin de proche en proche
évidemment ça va déclencher des troubles
géopolitiques massif
c'est absolument évident deuxième
constat le conseil chose qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que dans un climat
globalement plus chaud il ya globalement
plus d'évaporation mais malheureusement
cette évaporation ne conduira pas des
précipitations qui augmente partout le
surplus global de précipitations sur
terre sera mal répartie il ya des zones
dans lesquelles les précipitations vont
beaucoup augmenter
typiquement les hauts plateaux du nord
et des zones notamment le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen donc nous on est
aux avant postes où les précipitations
vont significativement diminué en plus
du fait que les précipitations diminué
vous le constatez probablement si vous
allez faire un tour dans la nature pas
très loin d'ici à précipitations
constantes si les températures
augmentent l'évaporation augmenter les
sols s'assèche
même si les précipitations ne baisse pas
et ça les arbres et les cultures n'aime
pas donc ça va mettre sous stress les
arbres et les cultures et le bassin
méditerranéen et particulièrement aux
avant-postes puisqu'avec un
réchauffement de deux degrés on a déjà
20 % d'assèchement des sols sur le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
alors une partie de ce pur tour c'est
tous les pays de la rive sud qui sont
déjà pas autosuffisant sur le plan
alimentaire qui seront à cause de leur
démographie obligé d'importer de manière
croissante tant qu'ils arrivent à
nourrir les gens et des importations
et puis quand ils commenceront à avoir
du mal à faire sa ba c'est le printemps
arabe empire qui s'orchestre déclenchera
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer
donc les millions de réfugiés en europe
c'est marrant parce que je suis passé
juste avant à une émission de radio on
m'a demandé ce que je pensais de la
votation qui allait être proposé aux
suisses sur l'immigration alors ma
réponse a été la pression extérieure va
augmenter de toute façon à cause de ce
problème là et d'autres problèmes
et si vous voulez être bien protégé
contre l'immigration il est plus urgent
d'aller mettre beaucoup de pognon dans
les pays qui ont un de l'émigration
possible à vous proposer
plutôt que de penser que vous allez vous
barricadez ici parce que ça résistera
qu'un temps quoi là vous avez
l'évolution de l'humidité des sols et du
coup l'évolution des rendements
agricoles derrière et je vais aller
directement à ce graphique qui date d'il
ya un an + ou - qui vient du giec et qui
vous dit que à partir de 2 degrés et
demi à 3 degré d'élévation de
température vous avez de l'insécurité
alimentaire qui commence à se
généraliser sur la planète alors tous
ceux d'entre vous qui ont lu leurs cours
d'histoire attentivement se rappelleront
que l'insécurité alimentaire et le
premier ferment d'instabilité politique
à partir du moment où les gens n'ont pas
à bout fait il se révolte ça marche très
très bien nous on a coupé la tête de nos
3 on le regrette un peu maintenant parce
qu'on a personne à mettre dans gala on
est objet d'élire un président pour ça
mais sinon c'est évident que c'est
quelque chose qui va beaucoup bouger
alors quelque chose que j'ai oublié de
dire aussi mais que je vais vous dire
tout de suite dans le monde économique
en particulier dans le monde économique
en particulier on a tendance à être
comment dire à être trompés par les
raisonnements linéaire une action
beaucoup de 100 euros donc deux actions
me coûte 200 euros et on transpose ses
rayonnements linéaire au monde physique
qui lui n'est pas linéaire donc beaucoup
de gens se disent 2 degrés c'est deux
fois plus grave que 1 degré je vais
prendre un exemple si votre propre corps
de temps en temps il arrive à votre
propre corps de connaître une élévation
de température s'appelle avoir la fièvre
alors si vous avez une élévation de
température de 20 degrés le tampon mal
foutu bon pas trop trop grave si vous
êtes très motivé ou viendrait même ici
parce que les petits fours sont bons si
vous avez une élévation de température
de 5 degrés vous allez pas rater cinq
cocktails vous êtes mort
donc votre corps qui est un système
parfaitement non linéaire vous voyez
bien que les conséquences ne sont pas
une fonction linéaire de l'élévation de
température les conséquences augmentent
beaucoup plus vite que l'élévation de
température est bien pour la planète
c'est exactement pareil donc 2 degrés
c'est pas deux fois plus grave qu'un
degré c'est probablement 50 fois plus
grave qu'un degré et 3 degrés s'est
probablement dit mille fois plus grave
qu'un degré alors donc le l'élévation là
en ce moment vous avez déjà plein de
coraux qui s'offre à 2 degrés sur tous
morts par exemple donc 25 % des espèces
marines qui sont dépendantes des récifs
coralliens aujourd'hui peut-être qu'ils
arrêteront mazzarri vont d'ailleurs je
sais pas où mais si elles n'y arrivent
pas disparaissent voilà voilà un exemple
parmi d'autres donc il faut bien
comprendre encore une fois que chaque
demi degré vous amènera un surplus de
conséquences désagréables peut-être
égale à la totalité des conséquences
désagréables qu'on a déjà eu avant c'est
pas du tout linéaire comme comme la
fonction des dommages un tout petit
sujet je suis désolé de vous projeter
une carte de l'hexagone mais c'est pour
illustrer quelque chose de plus générale
je le redis il ne vous aura pas échappé
qu'une petite échappée par donc une
petite partie de l'australie a brûlé il
n'y a pas très longtemps
en fait la partie de l'australie qui a
brûlé est très nettement supérieure à la
superficie de la suisse il ya à peu près
20 millions d'hectares qui ont brûlé en
c'est à dire à peu près 200 mille
kilomètres carrés
sauf erreur de ma part la suisse ne fait
pas une petite moitié de la france elle
est plus petite que ça donc on a une
petite moitié de la france en forêt qui
aurait brûlé en australie en sibérie
c'est à peu près pareil il ya eu des
températures totalement hallucinante
proche du cercle polaire au dernier
printemps avec des feux absolument
partout et en ce moment c'est en
californie qu'ils sont en train d en
train d'y passer à leur tour
ainsi qu'au brésil ainsi dans une partie
de l'afrique alors ce que vous voyez ici
c'est le résultat de ce fait le résumé
de leur chien je suis en train de vous
dire c'est la propension à brûler des
forêts françaises
à la fin du xxème siècle et en 2040
donc en gros et ça c'était une
simulation il ya quelques années j'ai
problème en train d'aller plus vite que
ça ce que vous voyez c'est que en gros
en 2040 n'importe où en france ça pour à
bord
et comme ça brûle aujourd'hui dans le
bassin méditerranéen sur la côte
méditerranéenne où à peu près dans
l'arrière pays dans la région parisienne
ça brûlera comme dans l'arrière pays
provençal aujourd'hui les phénomènes
extrêmes vont avoir tendance à
s'intensifier alors je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure que le réchauffement
climatique était un réchauffement près
de la surface
sait on intercepte les infrarouges
planétaire près de la surface donc on
réchauffe la température par la surface
mais si on intercepte les infrarouges
rayonné par la surface près de la
surface du coup il ya moins d'énergie
pour chauffer la haute atmosphère il ya
moins de rayonnement a intercepté dans
la haute atmosphère
donc le réchauffement climatique et
c'est une induits par le supplément
effet de serre et c'est une des ses
marques de fabrique qui permet de le
différencier de manière très nette du
réchauffement dues à la variation de
l'activité solaire c'est que il conduit
à un refroidissement de la stratosphère
donc quand c'est l'effet de serre qui
augmente la température au sol augmente
la stratosphère se refroidit quand c'est
le soleil qui est plus actif la
stratosphère se réchauffe
parce que dans ce que le soleil nous
envoya des ultraviolets qui sont
absorbés par l'ozone de la haute
atmosphère et si le soleil est plus
actif ils nous envoient plus ultra
violets et la haute atmosphère absorbent
plus d'ultra violets et elle se
réchauffe
donc quand la stratosphère se réchauffe
c'est la faute au soleil quand la
stratosphère se refroidit c'est la faute
des hommes et en ce moment la
stratosphère sont refroidies depuis qui
a des ballons sondes qui vont mesurer sa
température on sait que la stratosphère
se refroidit depuis les années 70 donc
on est absolument certain que ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est de
suppléments d'effet de serre et que le
soleil n'y est pour rien il ya d'autres
marqueurs qui permettent de le dire mais
ça c'est un marqueur absolument garanti
sur facture
tous ceux d'entre vous qui ont fait du
planeur ou du parapente le savent quand
les jours d'été vous avez un sol très
chaud et une stratosphère bien froide et
bien à ce moment là vous avez des
courants convectifs particulièrement
puissant et vous pouvez aller vous
balader au dessus du weisshorn comme je
les ai vus cet été eh bien c'est
exactement pareil avec les mouvements
convectifs qui met en route les ouragans
et les tornades
à partir du moment où vous avez une
température de surface qui est plus
élevé et une température de la
stratosphère qui est plus basse vous
avez un différentiel de température
entre les deux qui augmente
et ça ça augmente la puissance de la
pompe convective qui met en route les
ouragans les orages et les tornades
donc la logique veut que les phénomènes
extrêmes soit amené à s'intensifier
alors dans les phénomènes extrêmes là je
vous parlais de mais il ya aussi des
vagues de sécheresse il ya aussi les
inondations etc
enfin il ya tout un tas de trucs depuis
qu'on les mesure on constate que les
l'intensité a tendance à augmenter
le groenland a commencé à fondre
le groenland a commencé à fondre et à
partir de maintenant il va continuer à
fondre
quoi qu'on fasse parce que les processus
qui font grandir la fonte du groenland
créer des tas de processus
d'amplification de sa propre faute
le premier processus d'amplification
c'est que à la surface du groenland a
mené par le vent vous avez des
poussières quand la neige fond les
poussières se concentrent les poussières
fonde pas ça ça rend la surface plus
sombre et donc elles absorbent plus de
rayonnement solaire et donc elles font
encore plus le deuxième processus c'est
que si c'est la surface qu'ils font
quand la surface font l'altitude de la
calotte baisse puisque vous avez avait
un peu moins de surface et vous savez
bien que quand l'altitude baisse la
température ambiante augmente donc ça
fout encore plus vite et enfin il ya
troisième processus qui amplifie la
fonte c'est la fonte de la banquise la
banquise ne fait pas élever le niveau de
l'eau en elle même puisque le glaçon et
déjà posé sur l'eau mais par contre si
vous faites fondre la banquise vous
remplacer une surface très
réfléchissante qui est la glace par une
surface très absorbante qui est l'eau
océanique à ce moment plus de
rayonnement solaire est absorbée et à ce
moment là température ambiante de la
calotte augmente et la calotte font
encore plus vite tous ces trucs là vont
s'amplifier
donc de toutes façons la calotte
groenlandaise elle est partie pour
fondre et contribuer pour n'importe quoi
entre 3 et 6 m à l'élévation du niveau
de la mer dans les siècles qui viennent
de toute façon ça le coup est parti
et il ya probablement un processus
identique qui est en train de se mettre
en place sur la calotte antarctique de
l'ouest alors la calotte antarctique de
l'ouest c'est cette partie là il n'y a
pas vraiment de l'ouest en antarctique
puisqu'on est centrée sur le pôle sud
mais cette partie là il ya un certain
nombre de signaux assez inquiétant qui
montre que les glaciers sont en train de
flux est beaucoup plus rapidement vers
la mer cette calotte est posée pour
l'essentiel comme une bonne partie de
celles là aussi mais sur un socle
rocheux qui est sous marins et donc ça
peut être également attaqué par la mer
par en dessous
quand elles se réchauffent encore il ya
tout un tas de processus qui l'a aussi
s'amplifient les uns les autres et il ya
un vrai risque que ce truc là se
désagrège et contribue pour 6 mètres
d'élévation du niveau de la mer dans le
siècle qui viennent 6 e +3 ça fait neuf
plus la dilatation et bah ma foi dans
quelques siècles on pourrait avoir le
nord de l'europe qui ressemble à ça
alors bon vous me direz les suisses on
s'en fout nous notre littoral maritime
est réduit à une expression assez simple
je le redis si ça ça se passe en europe
du nord je ne pense pas que la suisse
restera indemne des conséquences qu'il y
aura en europe au sens large
d'accord on sait pourtant longtemps mais
enfin on pense que c'est pendant
longtemps
cela étant
le il ya des conséquences très ample
comme ça dont le doigt sur la gâchette
est en ce moment
autre conséquence je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'une partie du co2
atmosphérique passées dans l'eau pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont lu des violons
des vieux jules verne à vous vous
rappelez tête que le gaz carbone on
appelait le gaz carbonique dans les
temps anciens alors avant qu'on oblige
vos enfants à dire dioxyde de carbone on
leur disait gaz carbonique et avant gaz
carbonique on disait acide carbonique
pourquoi acide carbonique parce que
quand vous mettez le co2 dans l'eau il
acidifie l'eau et donc le fait d'avoir
du co2 qui passent dans l'eau diminue le
ph de l'eau et ça ça va rendre plus
difficile la synthèse du calcaire par
tous les organismes qui ont besoin de
synthétiser un squelette en calcaire et
notamment une bonne partie du zoo et du
phytoplancton qui synthétise des petites
coquilles donc les petits animaux marins
qui sont en début de chaîne alimentaire
qui ont besoin de synthétiser du
calcaire pour faire leur petit squelette
dans les animaux qui ont besoin de
synthétiser du calcaire pour faire leur
petit squelette vous avez notamment les
petits animaux qui ont donné lieu aux
couches géologiques de calcaire
aujourd'hui on ouvre pour faire du
ciment et des maisons ça c'est des
coquilles d'animaux anciens sédimenter
ces couches de calcaire
donc voilà donc on empêche ces animaux
de vivre dans un monde où qui va se
réchauffer on va modifier la circulation
océanique à large échelle
le climat va se réchauffer plus vite
près des pôles que aux tropiques dans le
cadre d'un réchauffement climatique dû à
l'effet de serre déjà un chimiste
suédois qui s'appelle arrhenius avait
compris sa en 1896 à part dans 18 156
excusez-moi j'ai oublié que j'avais
franchi les frontières et arrhenius
avait dit le supplément d'effet de serre
causera un réchauffement plus rapide au
pôle co tropiques et l'hiver que l'été
et la nuit que le jour c'est des causes
physiques aussi entrer dans les détails
c'est les causes physiques qui explique
cela du coup la différence de
température entre les pôles et les
tropiques va s'affaiblir et ça ça a deux
conséquences ça va modifier la
circulation océanique à large échelle
notamment celles qui nous envoie la
dérive nord atlantique qui est un bout
du gulf stream qui remonte mais ça c'est
également en train d'affaiblir le vortex
polaire qui est la délimitation entre le
climat polaire et le climat des moyennes
latitudes qui devient plus faiblarde et
ça explique pour
notamment en hiver vous avez maintenant
des élévations de température soudaine
extrêmement violente suivi
éventuellement derrière deux records de
froid juste après et bien ça c'est la
limite séparative entre le climat
polaire et le climat des moyennes
latitudes qui s'affaiblit et les masses
d'air qui communiquent plus facilement
entre les deux donc ça nous créé un
climat qui est beaucoup plus variables
et qui passe d'un extrême à l'autre et
le 1er janvier 2019 2018 je sais jamais
il y avait une température positive au
pôle nord 1er janvier températures
positives au pôle nord ou alors à cause
de cet effet de le candidat parlons du
coc vide alors le covin ne doit rien aux
changements climatiques a priori par
contre dans l'autre sens ça marche quand
vous chauffer le bouillon de culture la
biodiversité des agents pathogènes
augmente la nature aime bien être
créative en termes d'agents pathogènes
quand il fait un peu plus chaud et virus
et bien ça et les microbes aussi donc le
changement climatique augmentera la
pression pour qu'il apparaisse des trucs
nouveaux on n'avait pas vu avant ou que
des trucs qu'on avait déjà vue avant se
mettre à caen dira prospérer dans des
zones où il ne prospérait pas avant donc
il va y avoir des surprises sur le plan
des pathologies bon ça je vais aller
rapidement ça je vais aller rapidement
salua les rythmes ans et je vous demande
de bien regarder la dernière phrase
la dernière phrase c'est que si vous
calculez des value at risk
ça sert à rien parce que le risque vous
le connaissez pas la peine de calculer
l'évaluatrice sur un risque que vous
connaissez pas dans cette expérience que
nous faisons pour la première fois qui
consiste à faire varier le climat de la
même ampleur potentiellement qu'une des
glaciations sur une humanité sédentaires
de 8 milliards de bons hommes
la seule chose absolument certaine c'est
que nous ne verrons pas arrivé à l'as
vence toutes les conséquences possibles
et comme le dictionnaire est bien fait
ça s'appelle une surprise donc à mesure
que le climat se réchauffera nous
verrons arriver en quantité croissante
des conséquences imprévues désagréable
en quantité croissante
voilà c'est écrit faut pas demander à la
science de vous faire le menu du
restaurant tout étant écrit al avance et
dites-moi si dans les champignons
émincés vous en a émis 4 ou 5
pas la peine la science sera à jamais
incapable de vous faire un tableau
prédictif complet des risques que nous
pouvons courir ce que je viens de vous
donner comme liste ce soir c'est à peu
près le meilleur de ce que vous aurez en
termes de visibilité d'ensemble sur les
risques que nous courons
alors mon sentiment c'est qu'il ya pas
besoin de plus c'est à dire que mon
sentiment c'est que quand on crée ta
toune baird voit ça et qu'elle nous dit
mais vous la génération d'avant là
qu'est ce que vous foutez on a
l'impression que ça vous indiffère
totalement bâle a raison parce que
effectivement on en sait bien assez pour
commencer à s'exciter sur la question
voilà le fait qu'on ne le fasse pas mais
alors il ya un défaut de connaissance
encore évidemment un
mais il quelque part encore une fois la
connaissance disponible est largement
suffisante pour que l'on considère qu'il
faut qu'on passe à l'action
alors tout ça con mais ça pourrait
coûter et bien la réponse c'est
n'importe quoi entre zéro et l'infini
puisque comme vous le savez et je vais
vous montrer dans pas longtemps les
ressources naturelles sont toutes
gratuites par convention dans le système
économique donc le système climatique et
gratuit par convention dans notre
système économique vous n'avez pas une
seule valeur d'actions qui intègre
l'existence du climat d' accord n'existe
pas et comme c'est quand un actif et
gratuit le dommage à un actif qui vaut
bien haut dans combien vaut le fait de
fiche en l'air le système climatique 0
alors en fait on essaye de contourner le
problème en disant on va on va essayer
de voir quelle perte de pib on pourrait
avoir si on touche à un actif qui est
gratuit et qui intervient quand même
dans le fait qu'on ait un pib et bien la
réponse à cette question c'est alors ce
qui est rigolo c'est que jusqu'à
maintenant le comme ça ça donnait la
valeur de gauche que vous avez sur ce
tableau un peu compliqué je vais surtout
vous faire un zoom sur la valeur de
droite il ya des économistes
alors c'est très rigolo parce que ils
sont à l'université de chicago vous
savez l'université de chicago c'est
l'université de rockefeller de milton
friedman
c'est à dire celle qui a fait que les
gens qui sont dans cette salle pense
qu'il manipule une donnée à savoir un
prix dans lequel toute l'information
nécessaire est contenue dans le prix
c'est ce à l'université de chicago et
milton friedman or malheureusement c'est
pas du tout vrai vous allez voir dans
pas longtemps et c'est très rigolo de
voir que c'est de cette université que
via un article qui est paru il ya une
semaine dans lequel il dit ouais
fa si on regarde toutes les conséquences
et bien le coût de la tonne de co2
pourraient surtout de la tonne de
carbone pourraient se balader entre
10000 et six cent mille dollars
alors je vais vous faire un petit calcul
tout simple l'empreinte carbone d'un
suisse comme d'un français parce qu'on
est à peu près dans les mêmes eaux se
balade entre 10 et 15 tonnes de co2 par
an c'est à dire que si je fais les
émissions nécessaire à tous les produits
et services consommés par un suisse
moyen ou un français moyen sa chambre ou
dans cette salle vous êtes très au
dessus du suisse moyen donc votre
empreinte carbone est bien plus
importante notamment et salles toutes
les études le montrent vous prenez
beaucoup plus l'avion que la moyenne et
bien
l'avion était vraiment un transport de
riches quand vous regardez le la
distribution social du transport aérien
et bien à 15 tonnes de co2
faut pas me sentir comme une agression
c'est une réalité factuelle à 15 tonnes
de co2 par personne
si la tonne de carbone allez est à cent
mille dollars
donc la tonne de co2
pendant oui c'est certain de co2 à 300
mille dollars eh bien vous avez qu'un
soit 300 milles 4 millions et demi de
dollars de coût du changement climatique
pour le mode de vie qu'on a aujourd'hui
par personne alors que la même personne
va ramener 30000 dollars de pib par an
donc ce que vous disent les économies
cela c'est que on peut justifier d'une
valeur économique du changement
climatique qui fait qu'à chaque fois
qu'on fait un dollars de pib on croit
qu'on s'enrichit en fait non on est
juste en train de s'appauvrir
monstrueusement c'est une autre manière
de dire que la réparation des dommages
sera totalement hors de portée de
l'économie celui d'autres manières de
dire ça alors à ce stade vous m'avez
bien écoutez vous dites bon très bien on
passer à l'action et incompris on va
investir dans les éoliennes vous allez
voir c'est malheureusement un peu plus
compliqué que ça et on va prendre le
début du chemin qui va nous amener vers
les questions sur ce sujet là vous avez
ici un ensemble de courbes qui vous
donne la réponse à une question qui est
de combien se réchauffe le système
climatique planétaire entre le début de
l'ère industrielle allez on va dire 250
et 2100 en fonction de la quantité
totale de co2 que j'ai mis dans
l'atmosphère entre 1850 et 2100 alors le
début c'est pas exactement pareil 158,70
on s'en fou entre 850 et 860 10 par an
70 il s'est passé tellement peu de
choses que ça compte pas au regard de ce
qui s'est passé derrière
donc je regarde les émissions globales
sur le siècle et demi qui va de 1850 à
2100 et ce à me donne l'élévation de
température que j'aurais entre 850 et 2
mixant alors application pratique j'ai
pas encore fait le calcul pour 2019 mais
en france on ne sera pas loin à fin 2010
8 l'humanité avait rajouté deux mille
deux cent cinquante milliards de tonnes
de co2 dans l'atmosphère et donc nous
avons signé pour une élévation de
température de 25 degrés dont 1,2 sont
déjà visibles et les 0 3 ils sont juste
des gens embarqués dans nos émissions
passées donc demain matin j'arrête des
maîtres toute façon on tape les 1,5
degré même si ça déplaît aux
nations-unies à côté qui ont fait signer
à paris un accord comme quoi on allait
se limite à ça on s'en fout la physique
vous dis 1,5 degré s'est embarqué dans
nos amis
on passait ça y est c'est terminé on
peut plus rien faire contre si on veut
se limiter à 2 degrés ce qui est les
grandes déclarations larmoyante le coeur
sur la main sur le coeur des pays à
l'accord de paris dans le grand
davantage une droite c'est que ces
objectifs donc nous avons une d'avoir
une réponse à cette question et bien il
faut limiter les émissions planétaires à
3000 milliards de tonnes de co2 dont
2250 ont déjà été émises donc il en
reste sept cent cinquante d'accord avec
moi en 1750 ça veut dire qu'il reste
pour le siècle à venir pour faire simple
le tiers des émissions que l'humanité a
occasionné sur le siècle passé toujours
pour faire simple avec une humanité en
moyenne deux à trois fois moins
nombreuses ça veut dire qu'à un gamin
qui n'est aujourd'hui sa vie durant
si on veut respecter les deux degrés il
a un budget carbone qui est entre le 6e
et le dixième de celui qu'ont eu ces
grands parents qui meurt le jour de sa
naissance toujours pour faire simple
c'est ça que ça veut dire dire très
simple les cas planter les éoliennes
ok continent en pratique ça veut dire
que les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre doivent aller très vite vers zéro
dans le très vite ça veut dire que dans
le 2 et la deuxième moitié du xxième
siècle
on est en 2020 un deuxième moitié du
xxième siècle elles doivent descendre à
zéro et ça veut dire que ça doit passer
par un point intermédiaire qui est que
d'ici à ce que mes enfants et mon âge
les humanise les émissions planétaires
doivent être divisées par trois d'ici à
ce que mes enfants et mon âge donc les
générations futures qui sont concernés
par ce sujet on les touche du doigt tous
les jours je sors d'un établissement
puisque j'étais à le pfl ce matin ce qui
est truffé de générations futures
d'accord il n'ya pas besoin d'aller les
chercher chez paou qui naîtront dans le
futur nom les générations futures sont
nés depuis 1992 année du sommet de la
terre où on a signé un texte où il était
question des générations futures donc
tous les gens qui sont nés à partir de
90 3 c'est les générations futures
d'accord donc les générations futures
vous les touchez du doigt pour ceux
d'entre vous qui les ont à la maison
tous les jours en rentrant le soir
j'insiste c'est pas dans le futur c'est
des générations déjà passé
donc d'ici à ce que mes enfants et mon
âge il faut que les émissions
planétaires soit divisée par 3 alors
pour voir s'il suffit de planter les
éoliennes on va s'intéresser un peu à 12
viennent les émissions planétaires
vous allez ici un camembert qui
représente les émissions planétaires
d'accord 20% gros paquet marron ça vient
des sols centrales à charbon donc les
seules centrales à charbon dans le monde
ces 20% des émissions planétaires là
dedans il y en a la moitié qui vient de
chine moitié du parc de centrales à
charbon est en chine
vous allez dire nous les financiers
maintenant on est propre on fait plus de
charbon ont fait plus de charbon il ya
plus de charbon à faire il se trouve que
le charbon il est en train de croître en
chine en inde et dans d'autres pays
d'asie du sud-est en europe occidentale
où le pic de production du charbon en
grande bretagne était en 1914 le pic de
production il ya un petit rapport entre
ceci et cela soit dit en passant le pic
de production en allemagne était dans
les années 50 sauf erreur de mamans et
papas ont plus ou moins le pic de
production en france il était dans les
mêmes eaux
donc en fait du charbon on a de moins en
moins en europe il y en a encore pas mal
aux états unis mais en ce moment est en
train d'être chassés par le gaz donc
c'est vachement facile pour un financier
de s'acheter un brevet de vertu en
disant j'ai investi pas dans le charbon
de façon n'y a pas de projet en occident
accessible aux financiers qui veulent
investir dans le charbon parce que les
chinois s'occupe tout seul de leur
charbon
donc ça c'est un engagement qui coûte
rien parce que de toute façon ça ne
concerne aucun projet intéressant mais
ça fait quand même 20% des émissions
dans le monde
ensuite sept pour cent des émissions
dans le monde c'est le fait des
centrales à gaz et à fuel surtout à gaz
je rappelle que le gaz a beau être
naturel c'est une énergie fossile
je vous rappelle que les chutes de
pierres et la ciguë c'est aussi naturel
donc c'est pas parce que c'est naturel
que c'est sans danger naturel c'est ça
veut rien dire en fait un tout est
naturel quelque part les cimenteries
donc le business de monsieur holcim
c'est 6 à 7% des émissions planétaires
rien que dans par an ces six à sept pour
cent des émissions planétaires et là
dans les deux tiers c'est la calcination
du calcaire c'est le fait de prendre du
calcaire caco3 de casser en deux pour
faire de la chaux vive qui mélange avec
des poudres de perlimpinpin vous fera le
ciment et de l'autre côté vous avez du
co2 qui part dans l'air donc un four à
ciment c'est un endroit dans lequel
c'est un four à casser du carbonate de
calcium en deux morceaux
l'un des deux morceaux étant du co2 qui
part dans l'air le reste de l'industrie
occasionne un gros 10% on va dire 12 des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre là je
vous parle des émissions directes dont
je vous parle pas de l'électricité
consommée par l'industrie qui se
retrouvent dans ce pack est là et ce
paquet là je vous parle bien des
émissions directes des hauts fourneaux
des terrains des usines chimiques voilà
des endroits par exemple on fabrique de
l'hydrogène si on parlera peut-être de
l'hydrogène au moment des questions
aujourd'hui la fabrication de
l'hydrogène ça vous aimait autant de co2
que vous voulez parce qu'il s'agit de
mélanger du méthane donc du gaz naturel
avec de la vapeur d'eau et de chauffer
l'ensemble très fort en brûlant du gaz
naturel
donc vous avez deux fois du co2 dans la
production d'hydrogène
une fois en brûlant du gaz naturel et
une deuxième fois parce que le carbone
du méthane
il est retiré par l'oxygène de la vapeur
d'eau et donne du co2 qui part aussi
dans l'air donc aujourd'hui une voiture
à hydrogène ça crache autant de co2 on
analyse de cycle de vie qu'une voiture à
essence donc quand l'europe s'excite en
disant on va faire de l'hydrogène puis
au début c'est compliqué de
l'électrolysé avec des éoliennes de
réussir le servira toujours compliqué on
va prendre de l'hydrogène qu'on appelle
gris au début pour se faire la main en
fait c'est d'hydrogène truffé de co2
d'accord gains pour le climat nul regain
pour rire liquide réel mais bien pour le
climat nul le les chaudières de
bâtiments
ces six pour cent des émissions dans le
monde alors c'est beaucoup plus en
suisse par exemple mais parce que la
suisse chauffe et climatiques peu mais
si vous allez en inde il ya peu
d'endroits où un chauffard il ya
beaucoup d'endroits climatise donc 6%
dans le monde
les transports ces quatorze là dans les
voitures ces six les camions c4 les
avions et les avions preco vide ses 2es
et les bateaux ces deux alors avant même
de rentrer dans le reste vous voyez tout
de suite que les voitures et les
cimenteries c'est un problème de même
ampleur dans le monde que la totalité
des moyens de transport c'est moins
d'émissions que les seules centrales à
charbon voilà vous commencez à avoir une
petite idée de
et alors planter des éoliennes pour
faire l'hydrogène pour sa plus
l'hydrogène pour sa plus hydrogène pour
sa plus l'hydrogène pour ça plus la
réduction du minerai de fer ici plus ici
plus la plus ces machins les ordres de
grandeur ne passe pas les genres de
vendeurs 20% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sont liées à
l'agriculture
il s'agit là des émissions des vaches
alors je suis désolé de dire ça aux pays
d airain cdci men talent mais les vaches
sont très mal élevé elle roth
elles ont un élément de supériorité sur
les hommes c'est qu'elles ont quatre
estomacs comme vous le savez la panse le
bonnet la caillette et le feuillet qui
ont les très bonnes trip ensuite met
donc les vaches grotte du méthane et
vous avez deux grandes sources de
méthane dans le monde dans le monde
agricole c'est l'élevage des ruminants
et les rizières
il ya assez peu de rizières en suisse
quelques matchs tous les ruminants à les
chèvres les moutons etc j'ai surtout les
vaches et puis vous avez également les
émanations de méthane des déjections et
vous avez également les émanations de
protoxyde d'azoté des engrais quand on
utilise des engrais azotés qu'on les met
par terre vous avez du protoxyde d'azoté
qui s'en dégage et le protoxyde d'azoté
un gaz à effet de serre c'est aussi le
gaz hilarant ou l'anesthésiant léger
qu'on donne à vos enfants à l'hôpital
parfums fraise ou menthe
il faut choisir 10 % des émissions sur
le fait de la déforestation dans la
déforestation sur terre c'est très
simple je coupe le brûle pour laisser
place à des surfaces agricoles
c'est le processus qui est à laval des
forêts de bornéo avec les orangs outans
devant les bulldozer que enfin cesser ce
procès cela les brûlis au brésil et les
incendies qui en découlent etc et c'est
essentiellement pour faire des cultures
qui vont être destinées soit au pays
soit à l'exportation alors on a donné 10
et l'huile de palme qui va à
l'exportation au brésil c'est le soja
qui va à l'exportation en afrique c'est
beaucoup des cultures vivrières
c'est pour eux mêmes mais partout le
déterminant est le même c'est pour avoir
des nouvelles surfaces agricoles
donc si vous aimez pas la déforestation
faut se préoccuper de deux sujets c'est
la taille de la population mondiale et
la part de la viande dans la ration
alimentaire c'est les deux drivers de la
déforestation
y'a pas d'autres macroscopiquement il
n'a pas d'autre et enfin les autres
processus
sont alors vous voyez déjà ça c'est 30%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
liées à l'alimentation ça en processus
direct et sans processus à mon bon ça on
va rien changer que les éoliennes ce
qu'on va faire là dedans avec des
éoliennes et enfin ici vous avez
d'autres processus le traitement des
déchets les fluides frigorigènes
de fait une partie significative de ces
émissions vient l'énergie mais pas tous
pas tous d'accord donc les émissions
hors énergie ça représente quand même un
gros 40% des émissions planétaires un
gros 40% donc déjà ses émissions là
c'est sûr que c'est pas en plantant des
éoliennes que je vais m'en occuper
ça c'est sûr alors maintenant on va
s'occuper des éoliennes et donc on va
s'occuper de l'énergie je sais pas si
vous connaissez cet homme pré retraités
enfin moi non maintenant il présente le
loto moi je trouve que c'était plus
rigolo de présenter ce jeu mais bon il
aurait pu demander à une assistance de
répondre à la question qui est qu'est-ce
que l'énergie je sais pas si en suisse
il ya un membre du gouvernement fédéral
qui est en charge de l'énergie
si on a un mais en france on a un
ministre de l'énergie enfin ou un ami
chargé de l'énergie depuis longtemps et
je ne suis pas complètement sûr que le
ministre en charge du portefeuille sans
répondre à cette question
pas sûr
quand on vous dit énergie il ya dans nos
cervelles un certain nombre de réflexes
pavloviens qui peuvent survenir je vais
vous en proposer quelques-uns dont aucun
évidemment parce que sinon c'est pas
drôle ne correspond à la bonne réponse
dans la salle dans laquelle je suis je
pense que le premier réflexe pavlovien
qui vous viendrait à l'esprit c'est
celui-là d'énergie c'est une affaire de
pognon à les énergies renouvelables
coûte moins cher que le nucléaire fait
c'est donc elles vont se développer à le
gaz coûte plus cher au moins cher que je
sais pas quoi donc voilà pognon d'accord
facture alors manque de pot cette vision
là nous induit doublement en erreur la
première raison pour laquelle ça nous
induit en erreur
c'est que quand vous regardez ce que le
monde paye pour son énergie
rapporté à ce que le monde gagne eh bien
il se trouve que l'énergie est une
petite facture la totalité des achats de
pétrole de gaz et de charbon dans le
monde
ça représente quelques pour cent du pib
mondial et à partir du moment où
l'énergie est une petite facture
eh bien on va y passer une petite
fraction du temps je ne pense pas que la
quasi-totalité des analystes financiers
s'il y en a dans cette salle est ce que
vous employez ou auxquels vous avez
affaire centre la totalité de leurs
analyses sur les perspectives
économiques d'une entreprise à partir de
sa dépendance à l'énergie pas
complètement sûr d'accord je suis même
sûr de l' inverse
donc à partir du moment où c'est une
petite facture on va y passer une petite
fraction de son temps or c'est ne pas
comprendre qu'on peut très bien
représenté une petite fraction de
quelque chose et pourtant avoir une
importance cruciale
par exemple votre cervelle ne représente
que 2 % de votre poids et je suis désolé
de le dire dans cette salle testicules
des hommes une fraction encore plus
faible de leur masse et pourtant ça a
quand même à tout petit effet sur leurs
comportements sains alors on peut couper
les testicules les gens survivent
il y aurait six chambres plus aiguë par
contre si je vous copie de cervelle la
session vous survivez pas donc si je
vous suppriment 2 % de votre poids en
vous enlevez votre cervelle et même la
moitié de votre cervelle je vous ai pas
supprimer 1 % de votre efficacité 1 % de
vos charges et pourquoi vous êtes mort
quoi bon
donc le fait que l'énergie ne vaille que
quelques pourcents de ce qu'on dépense
c'est pas la bonne réponse parce que ce
que vous allez voir un peu plus tard
c'est que 100% du monde moderne et 100 %
de ce qui vous fait vivre dans cette
salle en dépend 100 % de ce qui vous
fait vivre dans cette salle en dépend
vos revenus sont dépendants jusqu'à la
moelle de l'existence d'un monde dopé
aux énergies fossiles totalité de vos
revenus sont dépendants de ça donc
première mauvaise réponse
après il ya une deuxième réponse que
vous avez souvent qui est à vous savez
la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas si vous tapez je suis
désolé j'ai oublié vous mettre l'image
mais vous ferez l'exercice chez vous
plus tard parce que tout de suite ce
n'est pas le roi de regarder votre
smartphone si vous faites l'exercice de
taper dans un moteur de recherche
la meilleure énergie juste la meilleure
énergie et vous regardez ce que le
moteur de recherche vous suggère de
rajouter comme complément à votre quête
vous verrez je vous ment pas fait ça sur
google je suis sûr que ça marche il vous
suggère de rajouter est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas en français alors j'ai pas
fait en anglais le tester en français je
suis sûr que ça marche et bien un manque
de pot la meilleure énergie est celle
qu'on consomme
c'est quand même ballot et du reste si
la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas expliqué voit cette courbe
expliquez-moi cette courbe expliquez moi
pourquoi depuis qu'on utilise de
l'énergie on n'arrête pas d'en conserver
de plus en plus si la meilleure c'est
celle qu'on ne consomme pas pourquoi m
stupide si la meilleure est celle qu'on
ne consomme pas pour un conseiller de
plus en plus
non je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais moi quand j'ai la meilleure viande
séchée gp envie d'en consommer de plus
en plus j'ai pas envie d'en consommer
moins en moins et au contraire si on me
demande de manger un truc infecte chez
ma belle-mère j'ai envie d'en manger
moins possible et donc je vais pas à me
gaver quoi donc là manifestement c'est
la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on
consomme et vous verrez du reste que on
la consomme quoi qu'il se passe par
ailleurs et c'est essentiellement de
l'énergie fossile
vous allez dire ouais enfin maintenant
on développe les renouvelables machin
c'est un peu moins vrai alors c'est vrai
qu'on développe les renouvelables c'est
le machin vert rose que vous avez une
arme ça c'est les nouvelles
renouvelables dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial
donc c'est la somme avec en plus la
convention la plus favorable possible
c'est l'équivalent primaire pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont familiers avec ça
de l'éolien dont claire rose là vous
représente l'éolien et au dessus vous
avez le solaire que vous arrivez à voir
si vous avez de très bons vieux c'est un
tout petit filet jaune là et encore au
dessus vous avez la géothermie
dans les agrocarburants pardon et le
rose c'est l'éolien plus le solaire plus
le marais moteur plus le houlomoteurs
plus le biogaz plus la géothermie plus
tous les trucs qui excite les
journalistes et qui remplissent les
colonnes de journaux
alors ça remplit peut-être les colonnes
de journaux mais ça remplit pas les
réservoirs pour le moment c'est
totalement anecdotique dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
et la bonne question est de savoir si ça
peut devenir principal aux horizons de
temps des promesses politiques
hélas il ya des gens un peu joueur dans
la salle on va tout de suite chez le
notaire en sortant d'ici parce que moi
je vous parlais toutes mes économies
contre les autres que non donc s'il ya
des gens un peu joueur dans la salle on
y va il ya aucun problème tout de suite
petite observation du passé ici vous
avez la part de chaque énergie dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
et vous avez une courbe ici sur laquelle
j'attire votre attention qui est la part
des combustibles fossiles dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
eh bien vous voyez que la révolution
industrielle c'est augmenter la part de
ces combustibles fossiles jusqu'à les
mettre à 80% et depuis c'est à 80% alors
ça monte un peu sa baisse un peu en
fonction des proportions respectives de
charbon et de gaz du développement du
nucléaire du développement mais cela
reste à 80% quoi c'est désespérément à
80% depuis 50 ans donc l'idée que ce
truc là va descendre à 0 en 20 ans ato
cost d'un claquement de doigts je le
redis s'il ya des gens qui paris dans la
salle
je prends les paris demande aussi un
notaire dans la salle aussi je le
réquisitionne et on prend les pareil
tout de suite je vous parie la totalité
de vos assets under management contre
les modestes économies jeu sans hésiter
une seule seconde je prendrais sans
hésiter une seconde
ça veut dire évidemment quelque chose de
très désagréable vous commencez à voir
arriver mais je serai un peu plus
explicite plus tard qui est que de
régler le problème du changement
climatique sans diminuer massivement la
quantité d'énergie qu'on n'utilise
jamais on y arrivera et donc là on va
rentrer dans une deuxième question qui
est ce qu'on sait diminuer massivement
la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise sans
diminuer massivement le système
économique mondial
avec ça la question mais pour le moment
je vous réponds
donc de mauvaises réponses 3e marie
france à roissy les éoliennes faut 100 %
renouvelable
alors j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour
vous c'est possible c'est tellement
possible qu'on l'a déjà fait voilà par
exemple un moment on l'avait fait voilà
un monde 100 % renouvelable la suisse il
ya deux siècles était 100% renouvelable
aucun problème 100% de l'homme vous avez
ici un monde dans lequel les transports
sont renouvelables l'énergie
renouvelable et transport maritime sont
renouvelables les vrais tout est
renouvelable là dedans aucun problème
alors le seul petit conditions aux
limites c'est que pour le moment on sait
faire avec 500 millions d'habitants sur
terre et 30 ans d'espérance de vie à la
naissance
c'est juste ça la petite conditions aux
limites qu'il faut avoir en tête
sinon ça pose aucun problème d'accord
alors évidemment avec un peu de chance
en passant de 8 milliards à 500 millions
et quelques emmerdeur qui disparaîtront
au passage pour espérer que ça tombe
juste heureux mais vous comprenez bien
en voyant ça que reproduire le monde
moderne avec juste les énergies du monde
ancien dont nous sommes sortis en fait
les énergies renouvelables c'est les
énergies dont nous sommes sortis
voilà par exemple la marine renouvelable
il ya deux siècles et on s'est dit c'est
mieux de faire ça bon voici des
transports terrestres renouvelables ya
deux siècles et on s'est dit c'est mieux
de faire ça et puis voici l'agriculture
renouvelables via deux siècles et on
s'est dit c'est mieux de faire ça voici
de l'industrie renouvelables via deux
siècles et on s'est dit c'est mieux de
faire ça et voici un panorama de il ya
mille ans ou de milan et ya un siècle
alors si on pouvait faire une
civilisation industrielle avec juste des
éoliennes deuxième petite question pour
cette salle puisqu'on a eu besoin
d'attendre le pétrole pour y arriver si
la civilisation industrielle mare juste
avec du solaire et de l'éolien le
solaire et l'éolien ça fait des milliers
d'années qu'on en a d'accord on a des
moulins en europe depuis 2000 ans et du
solaire depuis 500 ans vit dans pourquoi
est ce qu'on n'a pas fait une
civilisation industrielle avec juste ça
si c'est suffisant pourquoi donc
peut-être que la question c'est que ce
n'est pas suffisant
petits calculs physiques imaginons que
je prenne alors au premier ordre c'est à
peu près le volume d'air de cette salle
je prends le volume d'air de cette salle
et je le fais soufflé à 80 km heure
quarante cinq pour ceux qui font de la
voile sur le léman ou pour ceux qui font
de l'aéronautique dont 45 le bol d'or
commence à trouver passa pas trouvé ça
très drôle
j'imagine que je fais passer se vend à
ce moment dans une éolienne
donc je vais obtenir de l'énergie
d'accord je met en action les pales de
l'éolienne et j'obtiens de l'énergie et
bien la quantité d'énergie que je viens
d'obtenir en faisant passer dans une
éolienne
le volume d'air de cette salle qui
souffle à 80 km/heure
c'est la même que celle que j'ai en
faisant brûler sa de pétrole
la même alors à votre avis qu'est ce qui
va être le plus simple pour les hommes
et femmes
soyons paritaire est-ce que c'est
d'extraire l'énergie 2002 c'est 5000
mètres cubes devant quand il vient
souffler je veux dire il en fait il se
trouve que je connais un peu le valais
qu'est ce que j'y viens c'est souvent en
vacances et donc je constate que sur le
lac léman de temps en temps il ya des
gens qui sortent en voilier mais c'est
pour dire qu'il faut utiliser un bateau
je la vois le pont d'ouilly
lamentablement là comme un drapeau en
berne
c'est juste pour dire qu'ils sont allés
sur le quoi bon donc le à votre avis
est-ce que c'est plus simple d'avoir ça
en volume d'une énergie extrêmement
concentré qu'on peut utiliser quand on
veut où est-ce que c'est plus simple
d'avoir ça en volume d'énergie
extrêmement diffuse qui arrive quand
elle en a envie
bien évidemment vous avez la réponse
c'est la deuxième ça explique pourquoi
l'éolienne aujourd'hui vous fournit un
kilowattheure fatale c'est à dire sans
stockage à quelques centimes si vous
rajoutez le stockage pourrait multiplier
sa part 3 à 6 alors que sortie du désert
saoudien le kilowattheure de pétrole
vaut une fraction de centimes
c'est à dire des dizaines de fois moins
et ça c'est dans un monde dans lequel
l'éolienne moderne et fabrique des
combustibles fossiles puisque déjà pour
vous sortir l'éolienne performante qui
vous sort le kilowattheure à 4 centimes
vous avez bénéficié du charbon pour
faire la métallurgie
marc en acier vous avez essayé du
pétrole pour acheminer les composantes
de l'éolienne depuis la chine où elles
sont fabriquées parce qu'un peu plus
mondialisé que le solaire et l'éolien
tout est fait en chine jusqu'à
l'énergumène de allemande ou suisse
et vous avez bénéficié du gaz pour faire
le ciment du plô de l'éolienne si
maintenant je supprime tous à penser que
l'éolienne reste à 4 centimes le
kilowattheure si on fait les éoliennes
suisse avec le cuivre suisse ça va la
télé suisse les suisses alors maintenant
on va prendre cuivre suisse aluminium
suisse fer suisses silicium suisse
magnésium suisse dire qu'enfin tout
suisse cois d'accord
extrait de terre assemblée et transporté
avec des éoliennes celui-ci les panneaux
solaires suisse juste ça pour faire la
métallurgie amont la chimie amont etc
à votre avis vous pensez que le
kilowattheure est à 4 centimes près x 20
facile d'accord donc aujourd'hui la
deuxième chose contre laquelle je vous
mets en garde
ne croyez pas qu'on peut dériver du
marginal sur du moyen de monde financier
passe son temps à faire cette erreur
d'accord ça ne pas voir les effets
système on ne peut pas dérivé du
marginal sur du moyen c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui un pseudopode marginal de
notre civilisation dopé aux énergies
fossiles vous sort de l'éolien à 4
centimes que vous pouvez bâtir une
civilisation avec le principal venant
d'éoliennes qui sont toujours à 4
centimes ça c'est une énorme erreur de
raisonnement alors je la vois en
permanence les derniers à avoir sorti ce
genre de conneries c lazar avant
bloomberg new energy finance etc
on passe notre temps dans le monde
économique a dérivé des raisonnements
linéaire à partir du marginal
c'est faux je garde mes étudiants ont
fait ça jusqu'en 0direct donc trois
mauvaises réponses
en fait la bonne réponse vous l'a dit
l'avoir d'armes maintenant on fait
l'énergie c'est iron man en pièces
détachées
c'est sur l'énergie l'énergie en fait en
physique
c'est ce qui caractérise la
transformation du monde à l'énergie en
fait c'est ce qui vous quantifie le
changement d'état d'un système pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont des vieux souvenirs
dans cette matière aride qui s'appelle
la physique donc c'est une grandeur
physique et ça vous sert à quantifier
combien un système change c'est ça
alors applications pratiques pour
utiliser de l'énergie il vous faut un
système qui change c'est à dire un
convertisseur c'est à dire une machine
donc en fait l'énergie c'est d'être en
quête pour machine qui sert à faire iron
man pour de vrai votre prague auch est
devenu un laminoir votre pied droit est
devenu un camion on domine vous savez
ces camions avec les roues qui font cinq
mètres de diamètre le camion qui fait 40
m de hauteur et ses gigantesques votre
gauche est devenu un télescope votre
oreille droite est devenu un satellite
votre marine est devenu un aspirateur
etc d'accord l'énergie c'est iron man en
pièces détachées
c'est ça l'énergie c'est des croquettes
pour machines qui nous ont permis de
devenir totalement surpuissant alors
maintenant je vais faire un petit test
qui dans cette salle a déjà fait
normalement vous n'êtes pas très loin
des montagnes dont vous devriez y
arriver a déjà fait 4000 mètres de
dénivelé dans la journée pas mal
et bien en faisant 4000 mètres de
dénivelé dans la journée vous avez
réussi à fournir un kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique juste ça ça fait pas
beaucoup et en faisant ce genre d'effort
vos jambes on fournit une puissance
d'environ 100 watts en moyenne sur la
journée 100 watts qui maintenant a déjà
fait de la soupe avec un mixeur à soupe
les salles n'y a pas beaucoup plus que
des gens a dit donc vous avez des
serviteurs partout où vous faites jamais
de la soupe je repose la question qui a
déjà utilisé un mixeur à souffre n'est
toujours pas très nombreux vous devriez
essayer c'est une expérience
intéressante
alors quand vous avez qui connaît la
puissance de son mixeur à soupe c'est
quoi la puissance d'un mixeur à soupe
ans en watts et un petit mixeur à soupe
c'est un vieux mixeur à sous vous avez
aujourd'hui dans n'importe quel
supermarché pour vous acheter un mixeur
irak soupe
en fait vous allez avoir un engin qui
fait 300 400 watts c'est à dire que
quand vous appuyez sur le bouton du
mixeur à soupe
vous mettez en action quatre fois la
paire de jambes de monsieur là bas qui
est capable de faire 4000 mètres de
dénivelé dans la journée quatre fois ses
paires de jambes que vous mettez en
action instantanément qui a déjà passé
un aspirateur
vous n'êtes plus propre que gourmands
c'est quoi la puissance moyenne un
aspirateur
à kilowatts très bien un peu plus
maintenant puisque un peu plus gros donc
vous appuyez sur le bouton de
l'aspirateur
il ya dix fois les jambes de monsieur
qui se mettent en action je peux taper
d'aller pour vous d'accord je pense
qu'il est plus payés du reste que le
prix de l'aspirateur
donc ça vous coûte beaucoup moins cher
d'appuyer sur le bouton de l'aspirateur
que de faire pédaler dix fois monsieur
au prix auquel il est payé qui d'entre
vous comme monsieur bayrou chez nous est
déjà monté sur un tracteur quelques
propriétaires fonciers et bien quand
vous montez sur un tracteur vous avez
600 fois les jambes de monsieur qui se
mettent en action où vous avez 60
chevaux de trait comme vous voulez
qu'ils se mettent en action
pour vous qui a déjà manipulé un engin
de chantier
une pelle mécanique un seul alors là
c'est plus les je suis désolé c'est plus
les jambes on va passer au bras c'est
vous prenez un engin mécanique de
quelques centaines de kilowatts un gros
vous avez des milliers de paires de bras
qui se mettent en action pour vous
instantanément voilà je continue un
camion c'est des milliers de paires de
jambes et à la mémoire industrielle
j'ai pas s'il y en a un laminoir en
suisse ou pas de laminoir non vous
importez l'acier dominé c'est que vous
apportez les voitures ça c'est sûr je
sais pas si vous importez bon bref en
france on a quelques laminoir dunkerque
on en a un faux sur mer et bien quand le
laminoir de dunkerque la mine
c'est comme si j'avais des x 10 millions
donc si comme si je mettais toute la
population suisse avec un marteau dans
les mains à taper sur la tôle que plus
de financier en suisse c'est tous en
train de taper sur des tôles pour
remplacer un laminoir qui à l'instant où
je vous parle est actionné par une
personne donc lui pour le coup c'est
vraiment et rodman à tous les sens du
terme
il a démultiplié le jour il rentre dans
la cabine de pilotage il à démultiplier
la puissance de son action par 10
millions ce que je suis en train de vous
dire là aussi soit dit en passant que
j'y reviendrai c'est qu'aujourd'hui en
fait c'est plus nous qui bosse on nous
on a le temps de causer dans des salons
luxueux et d'écouté des conférences dans
des salons luxueux parce que les
machines bosse à notre place donc en
fait aujourd'hui ce qui fait la
production mondiale c'est plus les
hommes c'est les machines les hommes
sont juste là pour s'amuser avec la
production mondiale
alors on s'amuse on sent du high
frequency trading on passe le temps quoi
mais on produit rien d'accord on ne
produit plus rien on s'amuse on joue à
des jeux vidéo c'est presque pareil et
on s'amuse pour un prix qui est ridicule
alors maintenant je vais plus parler
puissant je vais parler énergies donc
voilà l'exercice que tout à l'heure
monsieur a fait de pas être très loin de
80 kg vue de vue de là où je suis
admettons que votre camelback soit
vraiment très remplie il se débrouille
transpiré dans je vous colle 10 kilos
sur le dos et alors je vais être un peu
plus modeste
vous allez faites pas 4000 mètres vous
contenter de deux milles à l'est tant
pis pour vous serez un peu frustré et
bien si vous faites cet exercice donc là
c'est plus un c'est un demi
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique que
vous fournissez dans la journée pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ça rappelle des
vieux souvenirs ce calcul est tout
bêtement faisait feu en faisant un oeil
allen gh1 donc je prends la base fois
l'attraction gravitationnelle fois la
hauteur c'est donc dans le sens inverse
l'eau qui descend du barrage de la
grande dixence la turbine au monde si
vous faites ça un jour sur deux vous
fournissez 100 kilowatts heure par an
d'énergie mécanique
maintenant si vous faites un grand trou
dans la terre pour auch pourquoi vous
décaisser la terre ce que vous avez
besoin de vous des quais ces 15 tonnes
de terre un six mètres cubes de terre
c'est à peu près 15 tonnes de terre lors
malheureusement vous est dix fois plus
ridicule de mon grimpeur c'est 0.05
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
fournit de façon unitaire et si vous
faites ça un jour sur deux outre que
vous aurez mal au dos et des ampoules
fourni 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique à la fin de l'année 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
c'est la même chose que le contenu
thermique de la combustion d'un litre
d'essence
un litre d'essence contient 10
kilowattheures de chaleur
alors évidemment vous convertissez passa
en totalité en énergie mécanique
monsieur carnot vous l'interdît mais il
n'empêche que dans 1 litre d'essence qui
coûte le prix absolument scandaleux de 1
franc 40 ou un franc cinquante dans ce
pays vous avez la même capacité à
modifier l'environnement que dans 10 à
100 jours de travail de force un être
humain dans un litre d'essence
évidemment ce n'est pas le même prix si
vous prenez le salaire minimum français
qui est très en dessous du salaire
minimum suisse nous sommes des gens
raisonnables et bien vous allez payer
votre kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
que quelques centaines à quelques
milliers d'euros alors qu'en face la
machine vous rend le même service pour
un coût marginal de quelques dizaines de
centimes
et voilà pourquoi votre pouvoir d'achat
est ce qu'il est il voilà pourquoi les
classes moyennes ont émergé et voilà
pourquoi nous avons tous la possibilité
de nous offrir pour 35 heures par
semaine tout un tas de trucs dont un
paysan du moyen-âge n'auraient même pas
osé rêver dans ses délires les plus fous
nous sommes tous devenus des nababs à
cause de ça tous
alors vous êtes un peu plus des nababs
que la moyenne dans cette salle mais
nous sommes globalement tous devenus des
dames à bas
c'est aussi pour ça que l'esclavagisme a
disparu parce que si vous prenez un
esclave ce qui en général pas une
vocation de jeunesse il ya peut-être
deux ou trois endroits secrètement
inconnu connu seuls les initiés dans
genève où on y va pour ça mais sinon en
général c'est pas une vocation de
jeunesse d'être esclave
donc si vous prenez un esclave vous
allez avoir besoin de payer pour prendre
une personne contre sa volonté et la
mettre quelque part
ensuite vous avez besoin de la nourrir
et d'empêcher debout trucider comme dans
django
donc tout ça va vous coûter de l'argent
et bien si vous regardez le coût du
kilowattheure mécanique
venant d'un esclave vous vous rendez
compte que même ça ça va vous coûter 10
à 100 fois plus cher que la machine qui
n'a rien contre sa condition de machine
se met pas en grève a pas besoin de
prendre de vacances et travail pour ou h
24 donc la raison pour laquelle
l'esclavagisme a disparu sur terre c'est
pas parce que vous êtes devenu bon alors
que vos ancêtres étaient magnifiques
vous n'êtes ni plus ni moins tordue vos
ancêtres on a même code génétique et moi
pareil reste c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il n'y a aucune espèce de rationalité
à s'emmerder à servir de semblables qui
sont pas efficaces qui se révoltent et
chivu trucide alors que la machine est
beaucoup plus efficace pour beaucoup
moins cher quand l'énergie commencera à
devenir limité on verra réapparaître des
comportements malheureusement pas
sympathique des hommes les uns envers
les autres parce que nous aurons cette
auxiliaire qui deviendra de plus en plus
difficiles à mobiliser
alors voilà la quantité de conquête pour
machines mobilisés par individu depuis
un siècle et demi je vais pas commenter
salon ben voilà surtout ça je voulais
déjà dit je vais juste commenté la
partie finale qui est que vous voyez que
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne aujourd'hui est un peu plus de
20000 kilowatts heure par personne et
par an et avec ma petite équivalence qui
est qu' un homme au travail c'est 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
grand max mais ils disent pour certains
aller je fais du un pour un grosso modo
ça veut dire que en gros l'humanité
grâce à l'énergie c'est à dire aux
machines à démultiplier la capacité à
transformer l'environnement
parra factor asseyez-vous bien de
plusieurs centaines donc je vais vous le
dire autrement
grâce à l'énergie et aux machines le pib
mondial est 200 fois plus élevé que ce
qu'il serait si nous n'avions pas les
machines
donc si nous n'avions pas les machines
vous seriez hauteur business tout ce que
tout ce temps vous êtes dans cette salle
et moi aussi du reste je suis un enfant
des machines
vous êtes des enfants des machines ce
qui fait aujourd'hui l'économie mondiale
nécessiterait mille quatre cents ou
mille 8600 maintenant milliards
d'individus pour être équivalent en
termes de flux de tables de chaises de
vêtements etc et de smartphones si on
n'avait pas les machines non évidemment
on n'y arriverait jamais même dans les
délires les plus fous d'elon musk un
donc le ce qui fait le monde moderne et
l'économie moderne c'est les machines et
donc ironman en pièces détachées avec
ses croquettes pour machines très
particulière qui en plus sont la très
bonne idée de venir du sous-sol et de
nous laisser la totalité de la surface
pour nos besoins alimentaires ce qui
n'était pas le cas il ya deux siècles
parce qu'on avait besoin des animaux de
trait qui occupaient une partie de
l'espace parce qu'ils avaient besoin de
croûtes et là aussi on les mangeait
enfin mais quand même
eh bien à multiplier donc la puissance
de l'humanité par 200 en occident on est
plutôt à 500 et dans cette salle on est
plutôt à 2010 autrement votre niveau de
vie à vous et à moi c'est plutôt deux
mille esclaves qu il nous faudrait pour
l'avoir plutôt que 200 comme l'humanité
dans son ensemble
alors ce mode de vie a totalement
déformé la structure des métiers
malheureusement j'ai pas le temps là
parce que je vois leur qu'il tourne donc
j'ai pas besoin de faire ça
je vais passer à plus loin et je vais
directement venir alors tu es fact
économique et puis je vais finir par sa
voix là et alors là dedans il ya des
gens ont pas vu le coup venir
c'est à dire les économistes classiques
il ya deux siècles il ya deux siècles au
moment où on commence à théoriser
l'économie on dit l'économie doit
compter ce qui est limite ans pour la
production il ya deux siècles le monde
est infinie on vient à peine de
découvrir l'amérique on n'a pas fini de
trucider les indiens l'antarctique on
sait pas où il est on n'est pas descendu
dans la fosse des mariannes
enfin on sait même pas qu'il en partie
du reste donc le monde est tellement
grand et l'humanité pas trop nombreuses
on est 500 millions d'essentiellement
des agriculteurs que à ce moment là les
gens qui théorisent d'économie se disent
on fonce qui est limitant pour la
production qui est essentiellement
agricole il bon c'est le nombre de gens
qui peuvent travailler et puis agent qui
travaille plus on peut mettre des champs
en culture et puis le capital humain
déjà accumulé donc les charrues et les
terres quand donc les usines donc à ce
moment là nos amis de l'époque nous
disent je vais me limiter à ce qui vient
des hommes comme facteur limitant de la
production le reste je m'en fous je
compte pas et comme je ne compte pas je
le dis je dis je compte pas jeudi les
ressources naturelles sont gratuites
donc à l'époque monsieur s'est dit par
exemple 20% d'oxygène dans l'air ça vaut
zéro si je retire 20% d'oxygène dans
l'air et je vous mets sur la lune
certes peut-être que ça vaut zéro mais
le pib tombe à zéro aussi d'accord peu
compliqué d'avoir un pib prospère dans
une atmosphère pas respirable du tout je
veux dire vous bourrez et si les
conditions climatiques sur terre font
que les 35 degrés et s'étendent partout
avec 100 % d'humidité le pib tombe à
zéro aussi
or le système climatique n'est pas
représenté dans cette convention par
définition des ressources on a tous les
deux siècles après l'économie avec
laquelle vous travaillez et l'économie
avec laquelle je travaille parce que je
suis chef d'entreprise donc d euros gens
manipulent tous les jours un tous les
jours je vois ce que c'est qu'une
facture émise ou à payer un salaire est
bien a été bâtie avec deux facteurs de
production et vos analyses financiers
ils raisonnent comme ça le travail et le
capital humain et il suffit d'avoir du
travail et du capital et à ce moment le
supermarché rempli
et si jamais là
duction n'est pas suffisante et que ça
pose un problème c'est pourquoi on peut
être le cul des banquiers en botte le
cul des chômeurs et hop la machine
repart de l'avant alors ils vont me voit
il ne vous aura pas échappé que depuis
2008 ça marche pas comme ça
on a beau botter le cul des chauffeurs
et botter le cul des banquiers la
machine repart pas c'est à dire que les
gisements de croissance résiduelles ils
sont hors ocde et en ocde la croissance
est factice c'est de l'inflation
d'actifs pour l'essentiel il n'y a pas
plus de mètres carrés construits par an
il y en a mais moyenne 1 - il n'y a pas
plus de tonnes chargé dans les camions
il y en a moins
c'est de la croissance totalement
factice qu'on a fait depuis 2008 dans la
zone ocde est alors la raison pour
laquelle ça marche pas c'est que c'est
pas une bonne représentation du système
il ya d'autres facteurs limitants il ya
un premier facteur limitant qui sont les
ressources tout ce que vous avez dans
cette salle c'est des ressources
transformé par d'autres activités
il n'y a pas un seul truc dans cette
salle qui relève de la génération
spontanée un harry potter agité un grand
coup sa baguette magique en sureau et à
ce moment paf il apparaît une langue non
cette lampe elles existent parce qu'il
ya tous les atomes constitutive de cette
lampe
on est allé les chercher dans
l'environnement et on les a transformés
avec des machines elle même fait avec
des ressources transformé donc on a eu
besoin des ressources d'accord si je
suis au milieu du vide intersidéral j'ai
pas les atomes pour faire cette lampe
quand je fais pas de lampe corps je peux
faire cette lampe parce que j'ai les
atomes qui me permettent de faire cette
lampe sur terre donc c'est des
ressources juste c'est pas sous la forme
sous laquelle on aimerait les trouvez
donc on va les transformer et la
transformation en physique c'est du
travail
c'est ça la transformation et cette
transformation avec ce que je vais vous
expliquer ce que je vous ai expliqué
avant doigt un tout petit peu à nos
muscles essentiellement au parc de
machines et alors qu enquêtes spéciales
qui s'appelle de l'énergie c'est ça le
système productif mondiale le capital là
dedans c'est juste une boucle internes
au système
cet immeuble a été fait en transformant
des ressources exactement comme
aujourd'hui où des oeufs qui ne sont pas
des éléments de capital fois ci si vous
avez un stock neufs chez 1,16 à un
éleveur de poussins ça devient du
capital mais enfin chez vous non
donc le système productif physiquement
il a d'autres facteurs limitants qui
sont les ressources et en fait ici tous
les facteurs limitants sont présentés
puisque vous avez les ressources qui
sont limitantes le nombre de gens pour
actionner les machines
puisqu'aujourd'hui on tire plus qu'à ça
que les machines qui sont les 80 et
le nombre de machines et l'énergie qui
alimente les machines tout ça c'est les
facteurs limitants aujourd'hui mais là
dedans ils ne sont pas tous représentés
dans les chiffres que vous manipulez et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il n'y a
pas un seul modèle macroéconomique au
monde qui soit prédictifs
évidemment il n'y a pas un seul modèle
économique au monde qui représentent la
réalité physique
si vous voulez je rigolais un grand coup
regardez les prévisions macroéconomiques
des 20 dernières années
année par année et comment ça s'est
comparé à ce qui s'est vraiment passé
moi si j'ai un responsable marketing au
sein de carbone 4 qui s'amusent à me
faire ce genre de truc trois années de
suite je veux dire quoi je ne garde pas
non dans le monde économique ont les
gardes puis on continue à écouter des
conneries mais alors voici quelques j'ai
envie de dire traduction concrète de ce
que je viens de vous dire vous avez ici
une reconstruction du pib mondial depuis
alors je suis désolé excellent a
tendance à mettre le début de l'axé des
abscisses à 0 mais là il s'agit du
calendrier romain donc j'aurais dû
mettre un donc depuis la naissance de
monsieur jésus-christ voici à quoi
ressemble le pib mondial
alors vous voyez que pendant très très
longtemps la croissance a pas été un
sujet de débat parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas de croissance et retenir qu'à cette
époque-là n'y avait pas non plus de
démocratie gérer l'absence de croissance
dans un monde démocratique
j'attends de voir mais pour le moment ça
me paraît pas trivial promettre plus aux
élections quand il a physiquement pas la
possibilité de faire plus un jeu
complètement sûr que ce soit si facile à
faire
jusqu'au début de la révolution
industrielle alors il commence à y avoir
des poches de croissance la grande
bretagne etc
il ya une proto révolution industrielle
au haut moyen âge et à la renaissance et
enfin ça fait quand même pas grand chose
et puis alors là arrivent les
combustibles fossiles alors lara lovely
et les économistes nous invente cette
grande farce qui s'appelle la croissance
structurelle de long terme je suis sûr
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de gens dans
cette salle qui ont entendu cette
expression que de gens qui ont manipulé
un mixeur à soupe je me trompe la
croissance structurelle de long terme
c'est une vaste blague la croissance
structurelle de long terme comment
voulez-vous faire croître
structurellement à long terme n'importe
quoi sur une planète qui faisaient
treize mille kilomètres de diamètre ya
deux siècles qui en fera toujours 13000
dans deux siècles et qui fera toujours
13 mille kilomètres de diamètre dans un
milliard d'années
si vous voulez faire croire
structurellement à long terme sinon nos
illusions donc la dure évidemment que ça
marche pas alors pour maman on n'y est
pas encore ça marche encore mais ça sera
pas structurelles de long terme
vous avez ici le meilleur modèle
macroéconomique que je connaisse qui est
une approximation des dernières années
ça s'appelle une droite un beaucoup plus
simple à manipuler que tous les modèles
qui portent des noms compliqués avec la
pub est une droite qui marche très bien
alors la droite elle vous dit quoi elle
vous dit dis moi combien d'énergie c'est
à dire combien de machines tu mets en
fonctionnement et je te dirai quel est
la production de ces machines dont je
suis capable de donner une contrepartie
économique qui s'appelle le pib c'est
très simple est ce que vous voyez là
dedans des monceaux d'efficacité
énergétique qui conduirait les points à
se comporter très différemment
moi je les vois pas aussi la courbe est
très légèrement convexe bon il ya un peu
des filles est d'accord donc là je vais
vous proposer une première conclusion
contracter fortement l'énergie qu'on
utilise sans contracter le pib c'est
juste impossible parce que c'est les
machines qui bosse pour nous donc
respecter les 2 degrés sans récession
nous n'y arriverons jamais alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est que si on respecte
pas les deux degrés on aura une
récession toute façon parce que
l'environnement nous mettra entre les
doigts donc en fait à partir de
maintenant notre choix c'est je
contracte de manière gérer ou j'attends
que les catastrophes s'en occupe pour
moi c'est ça l'équation d'accord
c'est désagréable c'est désagréable
enfin vous étiez dans cette salle j'ai
bien élevé vous n'êtes pas parti en
cours de route et vous avez ici
exactement la même chose traduit sur le
co2 d'envoyer pour le moment le
découplage massif
on l'attend et en fait ça ma théorie
c'est que c'est le reflet du
quantitative easing l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire l'inflation phénoménale des
actifs qui a conduit le pib a augmenté
de manière artificielle parce que quand
le prix de l'immobilier explosent et
bien les crédits immobiliers explose
tout autant vous avez pas plus de mètres
carrés à vendre mais vous faites deux
fois plus de crédit et ses comptes et au
nominal dans le pib quand la valeur des
actions double parce qu'aujourd'hui je
crée le site mon cul sur la commode
points comme et tout le monde se
précipite pour me prêter 2 milliards
enfin je veux dire quand on macro ont
dit on va faire des licornes à 1
milliard aériennes plus facile à faire
que des licornes à 1 milliard n'importe
quelle connerie points comme je vous
fais une licorne à un milliard c'est
juste pas le sujet donc ici attaqué au
sujet facile d'accord les sujets
difficiles c'est ça ça c'est un sujet
difficile
les corps d'un média on s'en fout jeudi
en plus je vois pas en quoi ça va
permettre de faire pleuvoir
sauf erreur de ma part donc ce que vous
voyez là c'est le drame des négociations
climat est en fait j'ai un ami qui
s'appelle brice lalonde qui est un mythe
qui a été ministre de l'environnement en
france et qui a été le sherpa de
mitterrand en 1992 au sommet de la terre
à rio des ministres de l'environnement
un gouvernement à cette époque la petite
très intéressant et il ya tout vu depuis
et il m'a dit un jour le drame des
négociations climat c'est que depuis
qu'elle existe
les pays en développement viennent en
pensant qu'on va parler de développement
les pays développés viennent en pensant
qu'on va parler de climat et ses les
premiers qui gagne et donc on a ça qui
continuent à aller vers le haut et la
droite c'est aussi bête que ça alors mon
système
il peut avoir d'autres facteurs limitant
donc qui peut avoir l'énergie fossile
comme facteur limitant à l'énergie et à
ce moment sa baisse la production où il
peut avoir les ressources qui sont
limitées et à ce moment ça baisse aussi
la production alors je vous le disais ça
sera de gré ou de force
alors qui dans cette salle a déjà vu ce
document a quand même on est par
l'ensemble vide
tous les autres vous auriez dû le dire
beaucoup plus important que de lire
toutes les analyses financières de chez
pas qui cherchait pas quoi ce document
vous dis une chose il vous dit la
production mondiale de pétrole
conventionnel
c'est à dire tout ce qui ne vient pas du
shale oil le pétrole de schiste
américains et des sables bitumineux au
canada est passé par un maximum absolu
en 2008 et diminue depuis qu'ils avaient
entendu cette conclusion déjà un peu
plus nombreux c'est l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qui a mis
dix ans à cracher le morceau alors ils
trouvent que par ailleurs l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie son analyste
pétrole je le connais bien parce que il
est en train de bosser pour banshee
project en ce moment de chip project est
en train de bosser en ce moment sur une
base statistique de la totalité des
gisements pétroliers dans le monde
un truc qui normalement vaut plusieurs
millions de dollars par an nous on a eu
l'idée pourquoi ces moyens là donc on a
eu pour beaucoup moins cher
je ne pense pas qu'une seule personne
dans cette salle qui a eu accès à cette
donnée là sauf éventuellement quelqu'un
qui travaille dans un établissement
financier très riche et qui investit
essentiellement dans le secteur oil gas
donc s'il y en a un dans cette salle qui
correspond à cette définition lui il se
paye peut-être cet abonnement tous les
autres vous y avez pas accès d'accord eh
bien on est en train d'analyser ce cette
base de données avec l'aide notamment de
cet homme qui travaillait à les yeux
donc je peux vous dire cette affirmation
la de l'eeie il faut la regarder de très
près parce que celle là est vrai corps
ils ont deux bras comptait pas de
conneries sur l'avion alors pourquoi je
vous parle du pétrole maintenant parce
qu'il se trouve que le premier facteur
limitant au sein de toutes les énergies
que nous utilisons c'est le pétrole ici
vous avez une courbe que j'ai que j'ai
fait par hasard en faisant des tests de
temps en temps je fais des régressions
comme ça vaut boire la gueule que sarah
et puis une fois que ça a une gueule qui
m'intéresse à ce moment j'essaye de voir
si je peux expliquer pourquoi donc il ya
dix ans de même 15 ans j'ai commencé à
faire ça sert que j'ai regardé comment
varier respectivement la quantité de
pétrole qu'on fait sortir de terre donc
ça c'est pas le prix c'est la quantité
qui sort de terre vérifie pas de lien
avec le prix derrière et le pib par
personne dans le monde il ya lorsque
vous voyez c'est que depuis la fin des
chocs pétroliers où on a beaucoup mieux
ajuster ces deux courbes ce qui est une
manière de dire qu'on a gratté tout le
superflu
il reste essentiel c'est à dire
l'énergie de la mondialisation et depuis
cette époque là il vous avez une
covariation absolument parfaite entre le
pib par personne et la quantité de
pétrole qui sort dans le monde
et quand vous avez un décalage temporel
c'est le pétrole qui précèdent le pib
donc vous n'avez pas la croissance
économique qui vient de mars et du coup
on n'a plus d'argent et on achète plus
de pétrole c'est parce qu'on a plus de
croquettes pour machines que nous avons
plus de pib parce que nous avons plus de
croquettes pour machines nous avons plus
de pib donc le meilleur indicateur
avancé de ce que sera l'économie de
demain
c'est pas les analystes qui sont faites
par les macroéconomistes je sais pas
quoi c'est la quantité de pétrole qui
sort du sol
or depuis le coc vide il ne vous aura
pas échappé que la quantité de pétrole
qui sort du sol a beaucoup baissé
donc je peux vous dire que l'économie
mondiale va être beaucoup des primés
pour un moment et là c'est pareil
s'il ya des gens audacieux prêt à parier
on va chez le notaire etc on peut faire
toute une série de paris chez le maître
d'hôtel alors je suis sûr
alors y'a pas de lien entre le prix et
les volumes de pétrole et voici un petit
graphique je suis sûr que dans vous avez
tous entendu parler d élasticité prix
volume d'accord savez l'élasticité prix
volume c'est je regarde la quantité de
ce qui est vendu sur le marché
et puis si l'offre augmente le prix
baisse et tous entendu parler de ça
alors ça doit être vrai pour le pétrole
s'il y en a plein le prix baisse s'il y
en a pas assez
le prix monte alors ici j'ai essayé de
faire aussi un petit est très simple
j'ai regardé depuis 1920 pour chaque
année combien valait la quantité de
pétrole offertes sur le marché qui est
acheté en totalité qui est vendu puisque
les stocks terrestres sont
infinitésimaux et à combien était le
baril alors si on a une élasticité beau
enrôler points et devrait être organisée
sur un truc qui ressemble à ça mais en
fait pas du tout si j'essaye de
théoriser cette courbe jeudi ya deux
régimes inélastique orthogonaux l'un à
l'autre un régime dans lequel quelle que
soit la quantité et le prix est le même
puis un régime dans lequel quel que soit
le prix un pardon pour un pour un
pour une quantité fixe le prix est
indifférent et on est reparti et on est
reparti donc en fait il y à 0
élasticité-prix volumes sur le pétrole 0
et la conclusion de ce graphique c'est
que si on a un défaut de pétrole
vous ne le verrez pas arrivée par une
explosion un défilé pris part
comme c'est un facteur de production
essentielle à l'économie mondiale si
vous n'en avez pas assez
effectivement dans un premier temps le
prix explosent mais si vous n'en avez
pas assez ironman commencent à souffrir
la production baisse
à ce moment la solvabilité des
consommateurs baisse est à ce moment la
solvabilité des consommateurs se
réajuste sur une offre qui a baissé et
le prix sar est d'augmenter
donc là le prix du pétrole poste pic ne
sera pas une hausse indéfinie du prix du
pétrole
d'accord ça va compact et le pib ça ne
va pas faire exploser indéfiniment le
prix du pétrole
ça peut vous paraître paradoxal mais
c'est absolument évident voilà j'arrive
à la conclusion de cette partie
introductive 6,6 et une partie
introductive l'humanité est maintenant
depuis dix ou vingt ans au début je
disais aujourd'hui en fait non on est on
est déjà bien aidé
on a passé ce point là à une forme de
croiser les chemins dans laquelle on
peut on est coincé alors j'aime bien la
théorie du do not que j'ai entendu ce
matin le pfl où on est coincé entre un
plafond et un plancher
le plafond c'est les limites planétaires
qu'il faut pas dépasser parce que sinon
le système se régule de lui même et
c'est désagréable parce que les
régulations spontanée du système a cédé
baisse rapide de la population et des
baisses rapides de son espérance de vie
voilà c'est comme ça que le système se
régule sur les populations animales
donc on sera moins nombreux et plus
pauvres mais vite et de manière peu
sympathique on sera aussi beaucoup moins
libre parce que dans ce genre de
régulation les systèmes libres et
ouverts saute tous
et inversement si on essaye d'agir trop
vite pour aller vers quelque chose entre
guillemets de durable à ce moment on
enfonce le plancher de la résistance
sociale c'est à dire que les gens à qui
on demande des efforts on leur demande
des efforts au delà de leurs seuils
j'ai envie de dire de résistance est à
ce moment le système craque par l'autre
bout donc
ou bien alors pour prendre cet exemple
appliquer au climat ou bien on laisse
les émissions dérivés parce qu'on se dit
socialement c'est impossible de
contraindre les financiers
à gagner moins d'argent c'est juste
impossible donc à ce moment on signe
pour une régulation environnementale
accrue
c'est le système qui nous imposera ses
limites ou bien on se dit non non on
veut essayer de durer encore un certain
temps je du reste on peut se poser la
question savoir combien de temps et à ce
moment c'est ceinture et régime tout de
suite et à ce moment évidemment la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
organise le moins pour tout le monde qui
en découlent on est coincé aujourd'hui
entre ces deux objectifs là et
évidemment les deux conclusions que je
vous livre en sortie si on veut partir
avec des conclusions un peu
opérationnels c'est que si vous voulez
j'ai envie de dire progresser dans la
façon dont votre activité demain peu
mieux prendre en compte ce que je vous
ai raconté
vous avez besoin de deux choses à minima
je dis bien d'autres choses à minima
donc je suis désolé je vais faire de
façon éhontée un plaidoyer pro domo mais
il se trouve que je fais le métier que
je fais aujourd'hui parce que j'avais
compris ce problème c'est pas dans
l'autre sens que ça s'est passé il faut
absolument que tous les gens qui
travaillent chez vous comprennent le
problème à traiter dont vous avez un
énorme problème de formation et toute
société qui se dit sérieuse sur cette
question pour moi elle n'est pas
sérieuse tant qu'elle n'a pas obligé ses
cadres à passer par 20 heures de cours
d'accord donc si vous ne passez pas par
20 heures de cours pour faire tous les
grands une bombe que vous voulez pour
moi juste on continue à bricoler
d'accord on est on est dans le bricolage
parce que le nom bricolage c'est de
comprendre le problème à traiter
la deuxième chose c'est que aujourd'hui
vous avez une comptabilité monétaire
exhaustive
tout y passe des achats de stylos
jusqu'au position sur le marché d'accord
et si vous voulez savoir si à la fin de
l'année vous porter mieux ou moins bien
sur le plan monétaire
vous n'allez pas commencer à dire alors
je prends juste que les trucs qui sont
débouclées à mon avantage des trucs qui
sont débouclées à mon désavantage de les
laisser de côté
et puis du reste quand je me déplace je
ne compte que le verre au bar et puis le
billet d'avion je n'en tiens pas compte
d'accord vous tenez compte de tout et
c'est en tenant compte de tous que vous
regardez si globalement vous évoluer
dans le bon comme dans le mauvais sens
au regard de cet indicateur
vous êtes obligés de faire la même chose
pour le carbone si vous voulez savoir où
vous allez donc vous pouvez pas vous
contenter
c'était là où je voulais en venir et
pourtant c'est mon métier de faire des
analyses d'impact sur les greens mon nom
je vois très content qu'il ait green
monde mais c'est pas le sujet face aux
problèmes que je viens d'évoquer il faut
pas faire un green bond il faut green et
tout lé monde et pour green et où les
bond
il faut passer tous les bond à la
moulinette de la comptabilité carbone
c'est exactement ce qu'on essaye de
faire chez carbone 4 et c'est ça qu'il
faut faire
d'accord l'autre jour il y avait bnp
paribas là qui a fait un post sur
linkedin en disant taratata on a financé
des panneaux solaires en belgique bon
alors outre le fait qu' on est dans
l'épaisseur du trait j'ai posé la
question en disant non mais c'est pas ça
le sujet c est ce que bnp paribas est en
train de se mettre en ligne avec une
baisse de 4% des émissions par an
puisque je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
que c'est ça qu'il faut faire pour tenir
les deux degrés donc est-ce que
l'empreinte carbone de la totalité des
engagements de bnp paribas vous mettez
en mesure d'y dépenser les quelques
dizaines de millions de dollars que vous
devez dépenser tous les ans pour
comprendre quelle est cette empreinte
carbone et vous lâcher beaucoup plus
d'argent que ça a des tas d'autres gens
pour faire des tas d'autres trucs je
sais très bien que le monde bancaire et
financier le premier consommateur d ss2i
dans le monde
d'haïti donc vous êtes un très très gros
consommateurs d'haïti ça vous coûterait
1 % de votre budget haïti d'y voir clair
sur le carbone donc aujourd'hui les gens
qui font pas ça ils sont juste pas
sérieux quoi donc la deuxième chose à
faire c'est d'avoir une comptabilité
physique qui vous permet de savoir à
quelle distance vous êtes du problème
est temps qu'on fait pas ça je considère
qu'on n'est pas sérieux alors les deux
positions que je viens de vous exprimer
je les ai publiées dans une petite
tribune sur un petit site modeste qui
s'appelle responsible investors il ya un
an je dis publiquement ce que je dis à
tout le monde
j'espère être utile en bousculant un peu
mais à l'évidence le début d'être
sérieux dans cette histoire passe par
les deux étapes que je viens d'évoquer
toute personne qui me dit je fais 3
green bond j'ai arrangé une éolienne etc
mais je ne fais pas les d'autres trucs
que je viens d'évoquer en fait c'est
juste pas sérieux voilà et comme mon
train et demain matin maintenant toute
la nuit pour les questions
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas comment ça marche il faut
passer derrière un micro alors la
session des questions réponses est
ouverte donc vous pouvez vincent autres
lever le bras comme ça je peux vous voir
et puis je me dirige vers vous pour vous
pour vos tendre le micro et puis écouter
vos questions je crois et bonjour vous
avez évoqué la piste de l'hydrogène et
qui fait partie des grandes décisions
qui sont prises par par deux grands pays
en europe
il ya des décisions d'investissement de
plusieurs milliards qui sont faits sur
secteur vu depuis l'extérieur depuis
infecté regard externe sur ces questions
là on a l'impression que cette filière
elle était un peu laissé de côté par
rapport à août à tous les enjeux pour
aller chercher de l'énergie un peu
partout sur la planète on a l'impression
que c'est une voie qui peut être
intéressante qu'on l'a laissé de côté
et puis tout d'un coup elles sont là
sort comme ça du chapeau alors moi j'ai
deux questions c'est pour quelle raison
on n'a pas traité on ne pensait pas
intéressé à cette filière autant que la
filière bois que la filière
photovoltaïque ou éolienne
et quel est votre pari dans les dix
prochaines années y sur la proportion
des deux vecteurs et énergétiques après
les investissements qui seront faits par
les grands pays européens
la réponse à la deuxième question c'est
si lon et ça a un lien avec la réponse à
la première question qui est l'hydrogène
donc là depuis très très longtemps
c'est pas un truc d'hydrogène est un
truc qu'on ne trouve pas dans la nature
et la seule hydrogène que vous trouvez
dans la durée de se former liés dont
vous avez d'hydrogène dans l'eau sauf
que pour casser l'énergie de liaison
entre l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène il
faut dépenser plein d'énergie et il faut
en dépenser plus que l'énergie que vous
récupérez en utilisant l'hydrogène
derrière donc en fait l'hydrogène n'est
pas une source d'énergie
le soleil c'est une source d'énergie
parce que vous avez une réaction
nucléaire permanente dans le soleil qui
amène de l'énergie dans le système les
combustibles fossiles c'est une source
d'énergie en fait c'est de l'énergie
nucléaire ancienne puisque
rhji soler ancien qui s'est concentrée
dans des petites poches souterraines et
aujourd'hui on peut extraire sa de
l'environnement avec moins d'énergie
pour l'extraire que l'énergie que ça va
fournir l'hydrogène vous ne pouvez pas
l'extraire de l'environnement avec moins
d'énergie pour l'extraire que ce que ça
va fournir cet objet de mettre plus
va fournir
donc c'est pas une source d'énergie
c'est éventuellement une manière de
l'utiliser mais vous avez besoin d'une
autre source d'énergie
alors aujourd'hui d'hydrogène il est
produit en quantité significative parce
que c'est une matière première pour la
chimie des engrais en fait l'hydrogène
est une matière première pour faire de
l'ammoniac pour faire de l'ammoniac
formule nh3 vous avez besoin d'azoté ça
c'est facile on prend dans l'air et vous
avez besoin d'hydrogène alors cet
hydrogène il est produit d'une façon
très simple on prend du méthane c'est ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure ch4 gaz
naturel on le mélange avec de l'eau h2o
donc tout ça est plein d'hydrogène
l'hydrogène de l'eau l'hydrogène du
méthane on chauffe l'ensemble très fort
avec du gaz et à ce moment vous avez
l'hydrogène qui se séparent à la fois du
carbone du méthane et de l'oxygène de
l'eau et le carbone du méthane et
l'oxygène de l'eau s'associent pour
faire du co2 donc aujourd'hui produire
de l'hydrogène il ya aucun problème air
liquide vous fait ça partout et les
grandes applications comme je le disais
c'est la production de l'ammoniac pour
la chimie des engrais est la deuxième
grande application c'est la
désulfuration des carburants donc vous
avez des unités de production
d'hydrogène dans toutes les raffineries
pour faire des carburants qui ne
contiennent pas de soufre donc
l'hydrogène ça fait très très longtemps
qu'on connaît on connaît on sait
également depuis très longtemps que
c'est le gaz qui est le moins denses
énergétiquement par unité de volume
or on sait aussi depuis très longtemps à
cause de monsieur marriott c'est sa loi
éponyme que la dépense énergétique liée
au transport d'un gaz est indépendant de
la nature du gaz
donc si vous prenez le gaz qui a la plus
faible densité énergétique par unité de
volume
c'est là que vous allez avoir les pertes
énergétiques les plus importantes liées
à son transport et son stockage dernier
point l'hydrogène est une toute petite
molécule
donc vous pouvez pas utiliser les
réseaux existants de gaz pour
transporter d'hydrogène parce que sinon
l'hydrogène va se coller dans les
microfissures de l'acier et fragilise le
réseau dans le réseau français de
distribution de gaz par exemple basse
basse pression celui qui arrive chez
vous
eh bien on peut mettre 6 % d'hydrogène
dans le gaz est pas plus parce que sinon
le réseau cas ce dont vous êtes obligés
de refaire des unités des
infrastructures de transport dédiés
et puis pour le produire de manière
propre alors j'ai fait un tout petit
calcul j'ai imaginé qu'on produisait de
manière propre c'est-à-dire avec de
l'éolien de l'électrolysé du stockage
tout ça n'est pas propre mais c'est pas
grave propre le l'hydrogène nécessaire
aux transports français
en france on consomme 40 millions de
tonnes voire le faire l'exercice avec la
suisse ce serait tout aussi démesuré
en france on transporte on utilise 40
millions de tonnes de pétrole par an
dans les transports pour produire la
même quantité d'énergie en hydrogène
pour alimenter les transports terrestres
en tenant compte du fait que les piles à
combustible sont plus efficaces que les
moteurs à combustion interne j'ai tenu
compte de ça eh bien il faudrait qu'on
double la production d'électricité
française pour l'électrolysé de l'eau
pour faire d'hydrogène et si on met que
des éoliennes pour ça parce que le
nucléaire c'est caca berck et le reste
et kaka berck et bien il faudrait qu'en
france on installe une fois et demi le
parc heureux le parc éolien qu'on a
actuellement en europe où il faudrait
qu'on multiplie le parc français par que
je dise pas de conneries 15 en disant
n'importe quoi
au surplus dans un pays qui va rentrer
en récession structurelle parce que je
vous rappelle tout à l'heure que à cause
de la décrue sur le pétrole le paysage
économique à partir de maintenant c'est
que en gros l'évolution structurelle
dans les pays de l' ocde ça va être la
contraction économique donc la
décroissance européens cherchent donc on
va pas avoir et l'argent pour payer ma
maison de retraite est la vôtre et
l'argent pour payer l'hôpital et
l'argent pour payer
j'ai pas quoi les smartphones et
l'argent pour faire la 5g et l'argent
pour faire l'hydrogène est on n'aura pas
été et c'est fini ça ça c'est en période
de croissance en période de non
croissance ou de contraction
si vous faites à vous ne faites pas b et
vous fait même pas un bout d'os et que
vous faisiez avant donc l'argent de
l'hydrogène
il ya un cas de figure où ça sert à
quelque chose un seul sait si on le fait
par électrolyse avec une source bas
carbone
pilotable de base donc j'ai nommé le
nucléaire et si on s'en sert pour faire
de la réduction du minerai de fer ou de
l'ammoniac pour faire les engrais voilà
donc il ya deux applications
intéressantes de l'hydrogène qui sont
pas du tout celles que l'europe va
financer parce que duclair ckac à berck
qui sont le nucléaire à partir de pardon
l'hydrogène à partir de nucléaire pour
faire soit de l'acier en réduisant
minerai de fer soit les engrais voilà ça
c'est les deux trucs intéressants dans
la mobilité on oublie on passe les gens
de la voiture au vélo c'est beaucoup
plus simple vélo électrique tout les
bagnoles que je vois dans genève là il y
en a 80 % que je peux remplacer par des
vélos électriques sans aucun problème
pour moi de ma bande par jour aucun
problème une seconde question une
question
merci j'aurais voulu revenir sur vos sur
vos courbes corrélés entre le pib et le
volume de pétrole extrait est ce que
vous sous entendez par là que c'est
l'opep et quelques autres qui ont dicté
qu'ils le feront encore un petit moment
le pib mondial la croissance et
accessoirement mon augmentation de
salaire à la fin de l'année on parlerait
de combat là c'est exact oui et non
l'opep est un cartel de producteurs qui
a été créée dans les années 70 si ma
mémoire est bonne mais bon j'ai plus un
trou de mémoire tout d'un coup plus et
qui avait pour but de protéger le prix
du baril de garantir le prix du baril
dont c'est un cartel qui est destiné à
garantir les prix parce que comme le
pétrole est une est une industrie
extrêmement capitalistique comme toutes
les industries très capitalistique c'est
des industries qui ont besoin d'avoir de
la visibilité sur le revenu est en
général aussi c'est des industries qui
ont des profits élevés comme la
pharmacie ou etc
le reste on le voit sur la course
d'après vous voyez le ca ca c l'opep en
fait l'opep a garanti la stabilité des
prix jusqu'au choc pétrolier depuis le
choc pétrolier l'opep contrôle beaucoup
moins la situation est depuis
l'avènement du shale oil ils la
contrôlent plus du tout au niveau des
prix parce qu'en fait l'ajustement
marginal se fait par le challenge qui
est beaucoup plus réactif
je creuse un trou j'ai tout de suite le
pétrole que
parler par les pays de l'opep alors est
ce que l'opep avait conscience du fait
que les pays de l'opep ont conscience du
fait que le volume de pétrole c'est le
pib mondial ça je ne sais pas s'il
agissait concrètement sur les sur les
volumes
oui parce qu'ils agissaient sur les
volumes pour gérer les prix en fait ils
n'agissent pas sur les volumes pour
gérer le pib ils agissent sur les
bouteilles que je lui mets corrélé au
pib
oui mais ça c'était pas ça qu'ils
avaient en tête ce qu'ils avaient en
tête c'était ça c'est à dire le fait que
le l'élasticité de court terme elle elle
existe et qu à partir du moment où il
pilote le volume à court terme il pilote
le prix à court terme
voilà c'était plutôt ça qu'ils avaient
en tête est ce qu'aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui par contre il ya un nombre
croissant de gens qui ont parfaitement
conscience du fait que l'énergie en
volume elles conditionnent le pib en
volume mais ça n'a jamais été théorisée
comme tel
j'ai envie de dire dans un modèle
économique aucun modèle économique à ma
connaissance ne nains pib en deux jeunes
c'est-à-dire un pib créé par le modèle
en fait tous les modèles
macroéconomiques ont un pib exogènes
c'est ça qu'il faut savoir
dix autres avant le pib est unique est
une hypothèse d'entrée mais qui est
modulé par d'autres hypothèses d'entrée
et qui vous est recraché modifié à la
fin donc au d'autres termes tous les
modèles macroéconomiques sais je suppose
que j'ai 2% de croissance par an en fait
c'est jamais une prévision c'est une
hypothèse de départ
et puis si j'investis un peu plus que
j'augmente un peu les charges sociales
que gelée baisse un peu et c'est en fait
c'est pas 2 c 1,8 ou ses 2,3 mais vous
avez toujours en entrée en fait un pib
qui vous et dont l'évolution est une
hypothèse c'est ça qu'il faut savoir
donc l'opep n'a jamais à ma connaissance
n'a jamais cherché à contrôler le pib
mondial à travers son action ils ont
toujours cherché à contrôler leurs
recettes à eux c'est à dire le prix du
pétrole
merci
il faut pas que les gens meurent avant
de sortir de cette salle la gamme
dommage voilà jeu il me semble qu'en
france vous êtes en train de construire
c'est les au prc oui c'est future
centrale nucléaire à fission nucléaire
c'est est-ce que c'est pas ça le fut la
solution la fission pour créer plus
d'énergie d'énergie finalement qui est
naturel est-ce que ça serait pas la
solution parce que moi je suis je suis
je suis comme vous je pense que le
nucléaire est une solution contrairement
à ce que les politiciens et les
écologistes pensent bien sûr ça produit
des déchets mais la conséquence par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit
l'utilisation du pétrole est quand même
différente donc ce qu' il n'était pas là
la solution le nucléaire aujourd'hui
fait de l'or fait un gros 10% de
l'électricité mondiale
le charbon fait aujourd'hui 40% de
alors moi il ya une application du
nucléaire qui m'intéresse c'est une
seule c'est de contribuer à tuer les 40%
de charbon ça ne m'intéresse pas de
rajouter du nucléaire en plus des
centrales à charbon existante parce que
ça ça ne rendra pas la vie plus douce et
mes enfants ils se prendront de la même
manière les migrations d'afrique les
maladies les forêts qui crament etc
changera rien donc si on veut que ça
change un peu
ce qu'il faut c'est remplacer le charbon
part du nucléaire soit dit en passant
l'allemagne est en train de faire
l'exact inverse et la suisse est en
train de lui emboîter le pas sans avoir
de centrales à charbon mais enfin est en
train d'abandonner
de lâcher la proie pour l'ombre si
j'étais vous moi j'aurais plus peur
d'habiter à l'aval du barrage de la
grande dixence que près d'une centrale
nucléaire
des accidents de barrage dans le monde
on fait beaucoup plus de morts que les
accidents de centrales nucléaires le
donc le nucléaire est ce que c'est une
solution alors c'est pas une solution
je vais vous donner ma réponse
ma réponse c'est que moins j'en fais
pour remplacer du charbon et plus
augmentent la douleur à laquelle je
devrais faire face la douleur globale à
laquelle je devrais faire face mais il
s'agit bien de remplacer du charbon il
s'agit pas d'en faire en plus du charbon
une fois je vous ai dit ça quel est le
bon nucléaire qu'il faut faire il faut
faire un bon arbitrage des risques entre
passé 15 ans à construire un réacteur
comme on a fait en france parce que on a
voulu prendre ceinture et bretelles sur
un modèle qu'on a conçu avec les
allemands le père est un réacteur
franco-allemand donc on a pris la
ceinture française les bretelles
allemande
on a multiplié sa part 3 on a fait un
truc beaucoup trop compliqué à
construire et où le problème le risque
concours en ne remplaçant pas
suffisamment du charbon part du
nucléaire en ne remplaçant pas
suffisamment vite du charbon part du
nucléaire est plus important que le
risque concours parce que le réacteur
pourrait avoir une défaillance
en gros si on est dans un arbitrage et
il faut savoir que ces modèles de
réacteurs il y en a deux aujourd'hui qui
sont open running en chine
absolument donc la presse française n'en
parle pas parce que la presse française
est globalement antinucléaires parce que
quand on écrit écolo on est anti
nucléaires et quand vous êtes
journaliste environnement vous êtes
écolo parce que sinon vous n'êtes pas
journaliste environnement donc tourner
les environnements dont vous êtes écolo
comme les écolos sont anti nucléaire
vous êtes anti nucléaire fin du
raisonnement
c'est en train de changer un peu en ce
moment mais on rame en fait le canada 2
up and running qui ont commencé à être
construit après le père de flamanville
celui sur lequel nous en pataugeant
france et qui ont été pendant aussi je
viendrai après et qui sont terminées et
fonctionne actuellement à pleine
puissance depuis aux six mois ou un an à
peu près donc dans le nucléaire il ya
deux sujets qui sont un peu différent il
ya enfin en tout cas vu de france il ya
la filière française
et puis à le nucléaire au sens large
encore la filière française n'est pas
représentative du nucléaire au sens
large les coréens ont construit quatre
réacteurs un peu moins puissant que le
payeur mais pas beaucoup
aux émirats arabes unis qui sont en
train de rentrer en service là ils sont
aussi commencé à être construit avant
après pardon les op le père de
flamanville et ils seront terminés à 6
milliards de dollars pièce alors que
nous à 12 milliards d'euros en nature
pas terminée donc il ya un sujet
français sur le nucléaire il a va me
permettre de parler après d'une des
conditions limites du nucléaire si on
fait un calcul d'investissement alors le
nucléaire pour moi il est à opposer non
pas au charbon parce que pour moi
l'équation est évidente nucléaire c'est
vachement mieux que le charbon
photo là dessus le charbon il faut quand
même savoir qui tu l'équivalent de la
ville de genève chaque année dans le
monde
en maladie professionnelle des mineurs
par le nepad la pollution urbaine il ya
10 millions mineurs de charbon dans le
monde dont une bonne partie dans les
mines artisanales de chine eh bien vous
avez 300 à 400 milles de ces mineurs ou
ancien mineur qui meurent chaque année
dans le monde des maladies pulmonaires
qu'ils ont contractés en se foutant de
la poussière à qui mieux mieux dans les
poumons pendant qu'ils faisaient des
trous dans la mine troc donc
l'équivalent de la ville de genève tous
les ans duclair fait pas ça à ma
connaissance
donc le donc il n'y a pas photo pour moi
sur le fait que c'est beaucoup mieux
par contre la question c'est une fois
que j'ai dit qu'on se débarrassait du
charbon vous avez un arbitrage à prendre
entre l'éolien qui est vachement bien le
photovoltaïque est vachement bien et le
nucléaire qui vachement mal en fait la
vraie équation et l'élan est en fait la
question c'est est ce que vous voulez
une fois que votre parachute dorsale de
marche plus un parachute ventrale
parfumée à l'eau de rose qui fait trois
centimètres carrés ou à parachute
ventrale qui pue mais qui fait 70 mètres
carrés
voilà c'est ça la question est en fait
le nucléaire c'est le parachute ventrale
qui pue mais qui fait 70 m² donc dans un
cas de figure est toujours debout rire
parce qu'en fait vous avez un défaut
complet de compréhension des ordres de
grandeur qui vont permettre d'évacuer le
problème alors que dans l'autre vous
prenez un risque mesuré limité de
pouvoir régler une partie significative
du problème mais vous allez pouvoir égal
donc en fait le compétiteur du nucléaire
c'est l'éolien le solaire donc la bonne
question c'est si je veux me débarrasser
du charbon est ce que je fais de
l'éolien du solaire ou est ce que je
fais du nucléaire et ma réponse c'est je
mets beaucoup moins mes enfants dans une
situation difficile
si je fais du nucléaire
ça peut vous paraître paradoxal mais
c'est ma conviction profonde le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on se soient précipités
sur l'éolien et le solaire pour faire de
l'électricité bas carbone
c'est la meilleure démonstration du fait
qu'on n'a rien compris au problème c'est
la meilleure démonstration du fait qu'on
n'a rien compris au problème et il n'y a
rien compris à la hiérarchie des risques
le fait que par ailleurs le solaire soit
transitoirement moins cher que le
nucléaire vient d'une comparaison de
chou et de carottes
si vous avez un panneau solaire à
l'heure à laquelle nous sommes
maintenant travers le rideau là bas il
fait plus très d'accord et bien le
vidéoprojecteur c'est un la lumière
s'éteint et si vous avez l'intention
d'avoir un plat chaud au buffet derrière
en sortant il ya plus de plats chauds
parce que il ya plus d'énergie pour
chauffer le plan d'accord
donc quand on compare du solaire et du
nucléaire on compare des choux et des
carottes parce que dans un cas de figure
vous avez le kilowattheure qui est à
votre disposition quand vous le
souhaitez et dans l'autre cas de figure
le train part à l'heure quand et du
soleil et arrivent à l'heure quand et du
soleil et quand ya pas de soleil le
train qui m'amène de morts jusqu'à y
circule pas d'accord donc en fait y'a
pas de soleil pas de conférence parce
que y'a pas conférencier votre moral
s'en porterait peut-être mieux mais faut
bien comprendre que c'est ça et si vous
avez un problème au genou
pas de soleil pas d'hôpital d'accord pas
d'opération voilà à 12h20 votre fils n'a
pas de bras pas de chocolat donc là
c'est exactement pareil
pas de soleil pas d'opération or nous
avons construit une société qui est
totalement basée sur les horaires ou si
vous prenez rendez vous avec votre
chirurgien pendant trois mois parce que
vous avez l'intention de vous faire
remplacer une rotule vous trouveriez ça
un peu étonnant dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui c'était
pas vrai il ya deux siècles que votre
chirurgien avoue 10h et désolé n'ya pas
de soleil donc l'opération non d'accord
et en plus variés même pas les moyens
d'aller jusque chez le chirurgien
puisque vous auriez besoin de l'énergie
solaire pour y aller bon il y aurait pas
de téléphone non plus pour vous prévenir
ce que pas d'énergie solaire donc vous
comprenez bien que un monde qui est
totalement basée sur les horaires ne
peut pas fonctionner avec une énergie
qui est disponible quand elle en a envie
alors vous allez me dire il ya qu'à
stocker jeudi à al arich d'accord mais à
ce moment il faut intégrer le coût du
stockage dans le coût complet vous
comparez donc moi je veux bien qu'on
compare le nucléaire avec un coût du
solaire stockée restituer ça je veux
bien et à ce moment il est plus du tout
à 40 euros le mégawattheure je peux vous
assurer que vous pouvez multiplier par
beaucoup
et le coût du stockage il est non
linéaire en fonction de la quantité a
stocké sur le coût du stockage le coût
marginal du stockage augmente avec la
quantité à stocker et non pas baisse bah
oui parce qu'au début vous mangez votre
pain blanc le premier la première pompe
à motech que vous faites
poste vous savez ou hypothèque qui sait
où et oytech quand il y en a au moins un
qui est allé dans le val d'anniviers
devriez y aller ce très joli donc la
première le premier à la première pompe
de relèvement qui est abu tech et qui
pompe l'eau de la visance du reste un
peu trop dur est parce que l aval ya
plus beaucoup d'eau vous permet de
mettre l'eau dans le barrage de moiry ça
marche bien mais vous repomper pas une
deuxième fois l'au delà des dix ans une
fois que les pompes et une fois donc le
stockage au début ça marche bien puis
ensuite ça marche moins bien et c'est
exactement pas donc donc le coût
marginal du stockage quand vous allez
devoir cantine stocker des quantités
massives il va augmenter il va pas du
tout baisser contrairement à l'idée que
l'on se fait donc si vous regardez le
coût complet du solaire plus stockage
vous êtes en dessous du coût complet
je vous parle pas des confidents des
frais financiers font part du coût de
construction d'un nucléaire même cher il
a juste pas photo et en plus on peut
rendre le nucléaire moins cher avec des
effets de série aujourd'hui en france on
réapprend je veux dire c'est un first of
a kind ça fait 20 ans qu'on n'a pas fait
de réacteurs en plus on a fait on a géré
notre filière à la petite semaine et
c'est une des limites aussi au nucléaire
c'est que le nucléaire ne supporte pas
le stop and go c'est une filière de très
long terme
et aujourd'hui les deux seuls pays qui
sont performants dans le nucléaire ou
les trois pays qui sont performants dans
le nucléaire sont des pays qui ont une
volonté constante de développer le
nucléaire
sur les vingt dernières années j'ai
nommé la chine et la russie d'accord il
ya deux pays aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
bons dans le nucléaire parce qu'ils
n'ont pas dit ah ben tiens aux
prochaines élections quand même salle
ferait bien que je ferme fessenheim
donc je vais dire que ckac à berck puis
au truc d'après julien nord quand même
j'ai besoin du nucléaire les mecs c'est
vachement bien ce que vous faites puis
au truc d'après john o'quinn 50%
nucléaire c'est vachement bien le truc
d'après lui dire non quand même les mecs
n'importe quoi c'est juste c'est un peu
comme si vous disiez à vos enfants le
lundi c'est les filières scientifiques
vachement bien le mardi c'est les
filières littéraires le mercredi c'est
scientifique le maire jeudi c'est
artistique le vendredi c'est d'aller
faire la cuisine et on recommence la
semaine d'après ça ne rime à rien la
probabilité que dans ce genre de
contexte vos enfants aient une éducation
structure est assez faible
bon donc le nucléaire ne supporte pas
les atermoiements constant et une
absence de cadre structurant de long
terme et c'est exactement ça qu'on est
en train de payer en france c'est les
conneries successifs qu'on a fait depuis
jospin qu'avant du super phénix pour
gratter quelques en gros tout ça c'est
des versions successives de je vois mon
droit d'aînesse pour un plat de
lentilles version moderne de sa le bloc
le nucléaire a besoin d'un cadre
structurant de long terme
c'est sa première limite et il a besoin
d'une présence limitée des gens dans
cette salle parce que si vous avez un
coût de l'argent à 10 % puisque vont
demander les gens dans cette salle
faites-moi du héros cea 10% à ce moment
votre mégawattheure vous coûte la peau
des fesses si vous voulez qui vous coûte
pas cher il faut du capital garanti par
l'état 2 % au risque de construction et
en ce moment ça vaut pas cher haïk les
punks le mégawattheure va sortir à 110
ou 220 euros avec le même coût de
construction j'ai fait les calculs
parce que le wac et à 10 % c'est très
simple on voit qui est à 10% donc
l'essentiel des 130 euros le
mégawattheure que vont payer les anglais
ça va payer des gens comme vous ça va
payer les frais fille le coût de
construction stricto sensu et de
d'exploitation sur la durée c'est entre
45 et 50 euros
même avec un ep air qui coûte cher donc
le nucléaire il ya deux choses dont il
n'a pas besoin je suis désolé de vous
dire ça c'est de financiers qui veulent
10% et d'un cadre oui j'insiste et d'un
cadre public qui soit bourré
d'atermoiements ça on est sûr que ça
c'est pas bon pour lui al'inverse quand
c'est une industrie dans lequel c'est
l'état qui investit pour pas cher
typiquement la chine et où vous n'avez
pas d'atermoiements à ce moment c'est
donc les opm chinois ils ont été
terminées sauf erreur de ma part pour 6
milliards d'euros pièce terminée il
fonctionne en ce moment voilà voilà donc
c'est la réponse à votre question alors
maintenant dernier point il faut
impérativement pour que le déploiement
du nucléaire soit utile que 1 on aille
vite
il ya deux mille 200 gigawatts de
centrales à charbon a tué dans le monde
dans les 30 ans qui viennent
2200 alors que le parc nucléaire
aujourd'hui ses 4 100 gigawatts corps
donc on a besoin d'une montée en
puissance très rapide mais par contre
chaque milliard de dollars investi dans
la construction d'une centrale nucléaire
qui remplace du sud
charbon est beaucoup plus efficace pour
décarbonés l'économie qu'un milliard de
dollars investis dans des éoliennes ou
des panneaux solaires plus le système
qu'il ira à laval poursuit privé du
charbon c'est beaucoup plus efficace
beaucoup plus rapide donc ça supprimera
beaucoup plus d' incendies de forêt de
mort des coraux de migration et de
misère voilà donc c'est ça ma réponse
les déchets c'est un non sujet technique
c'est un sujet psychologique la totalité
des déchets nucléaires du parc français
out durée de vie enfin à longue durée de
vie et à haute activité tient dans cette
pièce sur 40 ans d'exploitation d'accor
donc c'est bon très bien on le fout dans
un trou et on les oublie quoi enfin je
dirais même si ça peut être dans le trou
on a fait péter des bombes atomiques à
500 mètres sous terre et c'est par sorti
de terre donc je j'ai aura vraiment le
père de famille que je suis on met ça
dans un trou à 500 mètres sous terre ça
me va bien
tellement d'autres problèmes urgents à
gérer mon souci premier est ce que la
chine a compris ça oui oui est ce que la
chine puisque la chine a construit deux
ep r mes productrices où il on consomme
énormément de charbon ce qu'ils ont
compris les lisons dans leurs plans
pourquoi ils n'arrivent pas à leurs
plans de longères bon ils ont dans leurs
plans de long terme de passer à une
décarbonation de leur électricité pour
moitié sur le nucléaire et pour moitié
sur les nerfs et dans les yeux à terre
ils vont faire beaucoup de barrages qui
sont des oeillères qu'on peut aussi
discuter en fait on peut discuter toutes
les heures à partir du moment où elles
deviennent massive à lyon des
inconvénients tout aussi massif qui sont
pas le problème de la source mais qui
sont un problème des nuisances
quand vous faites le barrage des trois
gorges vous évacuer un million de
personnes
vous ne voyez quelques centaines ou
milliers de kilomètres carrés de terres
arables et il ya plus de dauphin et tout
un tas d'autres bestioles qui
disparaissent du fleuve fallait le faire
vous fallait pas le faire
bon voilà donc le plus grand lac de
barrage au monde il à la superficie d'un
département français fait 7000
kilomètres carrés je pense combien fait
l'état de genève en superficie c'est
quoi la superficie de près de 9
quelqu'un qui sait ça
devrait y avoir au montant
je devrais pas dire mais on doit être à
peu près dans les mêmes zones
donc voyez mon avis plus petit donc
c'est ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même un paquet de un paquet de
surface noyer
il ya eu beaucoup plus de morts à cause
des barrages kaposi du caf avant tout
les énergies renouvelables ont leurs
inconvénients
mais la chine en tout cas un programme
projet à long terme qui est de
décarbonés totalement son mix en
s'appuyant sur le nucléaire et les nerfs
électrique en la question c'est à long
terme parce que en fait la chine est
dans un combat ambivalent il ne vous
aura pas échappé qui est à la fois une
course à la puissance et à une rivalité
avec les états unis et une conscience de
la finitude du monde parce que c'est
leur histoire millénaire
parce qu'ils doivent nourrir 23 % de la
population mondiale avec 7% des terres
arables parce qu'ils sont passés par des
famines et des luttes internes
dramatique à cause des problèmes de
ressources parce que c'est un pays qui a
eu une ingénierie hydraulique
extrêmement développé avec les rizières
dans les temps anciens et donc les flux
physiques réels ils savent ce que ça
veut dire depuis très très longtemps et
les caprices de la nature ils savent ce
que ça veut dire depuis très très
longtemps donc je pense que la chine est
un pays est par ailleurs c'est un pays
qui a une organisation centrale depuis
longtemps donc c'est un pays
d'ingénieurs ancestraux qui par ailleurs
est dans une course à la puissance avec
les états unis
et donc ils sont coincés à mon avis
entre deux injonctions contradictoires
qui est qu'ils ont parfaitement
conscience du problème que je vous ai
présenté à mon avis beaucoup plus que le
pouvoir central aux états unis ont
marqué en ce moment c'est pas dur et de
l'autre côté
donc une prise de conscience et de
l'autre côté un prime de course à la
puissance et je sais pas exactement où
ils vont aller je sais pas si le savent
eux mêmes mais je pense que le il ya des
signes dans ce qu'on observe chez les
chinois qui sont des signes montrant que
ce truc là quand même été pour partie
compris on peut conclure que finalement
la démocratie est en train de tuer la
planète et puis que finalement les
vainqueurs se sont pas les démocrates
c'est pas du tout c'est un peu triste
parce que maintenant mais en baignoire
centrale est plus fort en terre ne se
discute pas et on va directement leur en
termes de supériorité des systèmes
politiques assurant la longévité à long
terme long terme des états vous avez
problème en raison des problèmes c'est
un peu triste
ça fait partie des mauvaises nouvelles
du jour alors après quelque chose qui
est absolument évident c'est que plus
longtemps on rechignera à faire de nous
mêmes des efforts modestes parce que
pour reprendre l'exemple de tout à
l'heure plutôt que de se déplacer dans
le temps que j'ai vu garé sur le devant
l'hôtel dans genève se déplacer en vélo
électrique c'est quand même un sacrifice
extrêmement mesurer le dire genève n'est
pas connu pour imposer 2000 mètres de
dénivelé ou 4000 du reste pour aller au
boulot tous les matins et quand on a un
vélo à assistance électrique
c'est quand même vraiment pas la mer à
boire voilà de temps en temps une flotte
parce que plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
la nature à ce moment où une cape
il ya trop de bagnols ont réservé des
péages versés passé comparé à ce que
j'ai racontée c'est vraiment un
sacrifice minimes juste ridicule les
marchés bon donc ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que plus longtemps on mettra à
consentir à des sacrifices minimes et
plus on signera pour des sacrifices
majeurs dont la liberté la démocratie et
c'est alors une fois qu'on sera passé en
dictature là aussi l'histoire nous
apprend une partie des riches passe du
côté du pouvoir et une autre se fait
passer à la trappe
à la tombée du bon côté de la barrière à
ce moment là
alors d'un heureusement ma forme qu'on
va devoir conclure cette conférence mais
l'événement n'est pas terminée monsieur
djokovic gens connaissent ils restent
avec nous un apéritif dînatoire et
services dans les salles en juste
derrière vous donc le l'occasion de
continuer aussi le débat le partage sur
ces sujets passionnants en cadeau bonus
je laisserai une copie de la
présentation aux organisateurs et vous
pourrez ils à leur réclamer
oui exactement et pour rebondir là
dessus si vous souhaitez revoir cette
conférence elle sera en replay
disponible dès demain sur le site www.ma
30 i series point ch
donc vous pouvez avoir accès librement
dès demain une petite information donc
pratiquer jeu ça rappelait les mesures
sanitaires les déplacements dans les
couloirs l'hôtel nous impose de porter
le masque
par contre dans les salles de l'apéritif
dînatoire n'y a pas de soucis vous
pouvez rester pouvait respirer à pleins
poumons sans ceci merci à vous merci à
tous pour votre présence merci encore
monsieur djokovic